thank you
i'll call the joint economic briefing to
order now
and our first presenter
will be doing it remotely
and is
dan white he's a senior director of
economic research
at moody's analytics you'll be
discussing the regional and national
economy
dan white
is a senior director of the economic
research at moody's analytics
dan worked closely with government and
policy makers and advice in an advisory
role
teaches classes on economics and public
finance at villanova university
he regularly presents to clients and
conferences
has been featured in a variety of media
outlets
ranging from cnn to the wall street
dan's most recent research expenses on
police policy responses
19.
including how the panoramic has been
employing how the public is happening
[Music]
policy issues concentrated around
economic development public investments
and depth management
dan holds an m.a in economics
and undergraduate degrees in finance and
international business
dan is yours and everybody should have
copies of his presentation and
you'll be able to see it on the screen
go ahead dan
on the screen
john do we have any technical issues
here
what did she say
what'd she say
looks like his image is frozen
oh there he
dan can you hear us on your side
i'm sad to say there's only two of us
here from the financing
oh wow
earth
and myself
now we have another one
oh god
dan if you can hear us on your side
you're all set
to go
yeah great i can hear you i can't see
you is that okay
i can hear everybody out of john's thing
i don't hear anything under the
chairman's thing
um but if you're ready i can happy to go
okay we're ready wonderful thank you mr
chairman uh i'm gonna share my screen
real quick just to show you some slides
uh that's okay
fine
so thank you very much for having me
here today i apologize that i can't be
there in person but i'm looking forward
to hopefully being there again with you
guys in person soon
uh i'm gonna share a slide deck
oops
how about this slide deck instead can
you all see those
yes
wonderful
you have to bear with me i'm not used to
using teams so much we use uh use
microsoft or we use a zoom in our office
most of the time
i'm going to share this other one and
sin
thank you very much for having me mr
chairman uh i'm going to
do my best to give you all a good
outlook for what the u.s economy is set
to do there you hopefully see the full
slide deck now
i'm going to try and give you a gross
overview of the u.s economic outlook for
the next couple years uh bearing in mind
that the outlook that i'm going to give
you today is very different than the
outlook i might have given you maybe
three or four weeks ago before the
russian invasion of ukraine so i
appreciate the the the serendipitous
delay in this uh because again the the
outlook has changed quite a bit i'm also
going to uh basically
present to you what our our baseline
outlook would have been pre-invasion and
then i'm going to try and layer a few um
risks and changes to the outlook based
on the invasion
as as a result of that um i'm going to
try and be as brief as i can and allow
you to ask questions as well
when i finish up i'll be happy to answer
any questions the committee might have
i'll also hint a little bit at some of
the the outlook that we have for the
state of new hampshire in general i know
you're going to have a lot of speakers
later today who will speak directly to
the the situation there in new hampshire
but i'll try and lead into those as best
i can okay
now i know that some of you have seen me
speak before at uh events for ncsl or
other events
but if you haven't seen me speak before
i do have to give a small disclaimer at
the beginning of my presentation so
my name is dan white for the record i'm
a senior director of economic research
at moody's analytics which is an
entirely separate company from moody's
investor service which is the ratings
agency that you might be familiar with
so the investor service is the ratings
agency movies analytics we are an
economic consulting and risk management
firm uh and so please don't let anything
that i say be misconstrued as having any
bearing whatsoever on past current or
future ratings actions uh if that sounds
like it was written by a lawyer it's
because it was but it keeps me out of
trouble as always have to do it before i
give my presentations okay
so with that out of the way let's get to
the economics so the first thing i
wanted to share with you all is
a really a 30 000 foot view of the
economy kind of going into the last few
weeks so this is what we would you'll
hear me talk about this a lot is our
february baseline forecast
what that really means in practice is
it's our pre-invasion forecast so this
is our forecast um based on the economic
fundamentals going into
uh the month of february uh i think it
gives some pretty good context around
where we've been in the last two years
and kind of where we would expect to go
all else equal again remembering that
right now in the world all else is not
necessarily equal so the pandemic
recession was really incredible it's
we've kind of run out of synonyms for
unprecedented so we lost 22 million jobs
in basically a period of two months at
the outset of the pandemic which is
something that we've never even come
close to before
the good news if there is any about a
pandemic is that it's very different
than a normal recession it's not uh to
use an analogy it's not like a car a
normal recession's like a car that ran
out of gas for example so it takes a
little while for it to get all the way
to the bottom and then once we restart
it it takes a little while to get going
again with the pandemic recession this
is more like an electric car that just
got unplugged we fell off a cliff almost
immediately in two months
there were non-economic factors
obviously the shutdowns and the kogan
restrictions that prevented people from
going to work we lost 22 million jobs
almost immediately
the good thing is though again we plug
it back in and we gained almost 10
million jobs back within a matter of
just a few months so by the end of that
summer we had a much more shallow
recession than we had originally
experienced it took us a little while if
you remember back a year ago heading
into the winter time in 2021
the vaccines hadn't quite come out yet
there was still a second wave of covet
coming around
it was kind of a scary place as we moved
sideways for a few months but once the
vaccines came online
once we started to lift a number of the
coveted restrictions and just as
importantly once we started to get a lot
of federal fiscal stimulus kind of
rolling through the economy we saw the
recovery pick up in earnest that's more
or less what we saw for most of last
year in 2021
so much to the fact that the federal
reserve was able to start beginning to
normalize monetary policy at the end of
last year you see this fed begins
tapering qe
qe is quantitative easing so it's
basically
they weren't necessarily tightening
monetary policy at that point but they
were they took their foot off the
accelerator so to speak
that brings us to more or less where we
are now which is the first quarter of
2022 we just had a very strong jobs
report come out this morning for example
the unemployment rate fell down to 3.8
and so now this has really cleared the
decks and allowed the federal reserve to
begin to normalize monetary policy in
earnest now there are a number of other
reasons why the federal reserve is going
to be normalizing monetary policy and
earnings that we'll talk about in just a
minute uh most notably inflation
but that's kind of where we are where we
expect to go now and i've kind of laid
these two kind of mile markers out ahead
of you
so that you can kind of gauge the risk
going forward um is the feds going to
begin to normalize interest rates at
their march meeting we expect to have
four
rate increases in this calendar year so
before december we'll expect them to
raise rates by a quarter of a percentage
point four times
um by the end of this calendar year we
would expect to be back around full
employment okay
so as a mile marker if we get to the end
of 2023 and a majority of economists are
not saying that we are back full
employment then we know that something
is going wrong with this forecast
if for whatever reason we hit full
employment ahead of time then we know
that something is going very right with
this forecast
but i wanted to give you these as kind
of mile markers along the way to kind of
gauge the risk that's associated with
some of the things that we're actually
about to talk about
all right
now you may be saying that this is a
very sanguine forecast in light of
what's happened over the last several
weeks
and you would be absolutely correct so
this is our february baseline forecast
um this is not our our post february
baseline forecast so our post invasion
forecast is quite a bit different and
we're going to talk about that going
forward
so one of the reasons behind the how
optimistic this forecast was and some of
the things we have going for
are um really some incredible um
[Music]
artifacts of the pandemic from an
economic perspective
now i'm going to leave this chart up
here for a second because it bears very
close scrutiny um when our team here at
moody's actually first showed me some of
this data
i thought they calculated it wrong
that's how kind of incredible it is so i
made them go back and do it again and
the data was absolutely correct so what
you're looking at here this is what the
federal reserve calls household
checkable deposits and currency so in
practice what that means is this is
money that is sitting in individuals
checking accounts their savings accounts
they're liquid money market accounts
within their banks this is all the cash
that people have on hand
so this it comes from the federal
reserve we have data back to about 1990
and you can see that in a normal year
especially in the last 10 years or so we
would expect for there to be somewhere
between a half a trillion and a trillion
dollars sitting in people's bank
accounts kind of aggregate over the
course of the or throughout the rest of
the country
as of the end of 2021 we're sitting at
about three and a half trillion dollars
in cash just sitting in bank accounts
right
so there's some good things here and
there's some bad things here the good
things
are that there's a lot of
demand kind of sitting on the sidelines
there's a lot of cash out there that can
be flowing towards greater economic
activity
the bad thing is that by sitting in bank
accounts this money is basically sitting
in the least productive place possible
from an economic standpoint so
um if this money were being spent it
would have obviously a much greater
economic impact if we're being invested
in more long-term assets as opposed to
sitting in bank accounts it would be
having a greater economic impact what
this is really an artifact of is the
fact that people just have a lot more
cash than they did
prior to the pandemic one the two
they're still very hesitant and very
cautious about what to do with that cash
there's so much uncertainty going on in
the world as a general
but especially in terms of financial
markets that folks are just really
putting this money in their bank
accounts
now the um
the one thing to keep in mind here is
that we don't have very good insight
from the federal reserve about whose
bank accounts this money is sitting in
right so
we don't know if this is just sitting in
elon musk and jeff leaders bank accounts
or this is pretty equally distributed
across the income distribution
anecdotally we we have a good sense that
most of this is sitting in what we would
term middle income
bank account so for 40 000 to
150 000 range in terms of the
income distribution
the reason being that if this was in
very wealthy households bank accounts it
probably wouldn't be sitting in a
savings account it would be sitting in
probably something that's a bit more
sophisticated from an investment
standpoint
however a lot of this also could be
sitting across relatively low income
folks households what we expect to see
is this is an artifact of
folks who maybe had never had much money
in their savings account before they now
have five thousand ten thousand dollars
sitting in a savings account either
because they didn't spend money during
the pandemic or um they've been able to
bank away a lot of the federal funding
or the federal assistance that's come
their way over the course of the
pandemic either way this money is not
going to sit in bank accounts forever
and that's kind of really the the key to
the next part of the recovery of the
economic expansion is where does this
money eventually go
and how quickly does it go how quickly
does it get out of bank accounts
now the other question that a lot of
people ask with this is kind of where
did the money come from
some of it is because folks pulled back
on spending during the the pandemic
but a lot of it is also the amount of
federal assistance that came to their
their households via the the pandemic
relief funds
uh and so it's it's important to look at
kind of
where we sit in the united states with
regard to that federal stimulus in other
countries around the world
this chart i think is very instructive
um in that it shows really how much more
we have done in the united states in
terms of federal fiscal stimulus than
other developed countries around the
world uh almost twice as much as most of
our our more
developed neighbors and competitors that
we have around the world
and i also want to point out that all of
the the
[Music]
stimulus you see here so the dark blue
is the cares act that was passed at the
initial part of the pandemic
we've got the december 2020 package
which um unfortunately didn't come with
a cool letter name so we just call it
the december 2020 package
uh apologies you do
economists are always really terrible at
naming things so we call the december
2020 package your american rescue plan
which you remember was last march that
came in shortly after the biden
administration came into office about
1.9 trillion dollars and then there's
about 550 billion dollars on the
infrastructure bill that was just past
oh gosh a few months ago so all of this
aid that you're seeing here stuff that's
already been passed this doesn't account
for anything that might continue to try
to be passed in some kind of form of a
build back better bill or any other kind
of reconciliation bill that might be
considered in congress this year
now when we show this when i show this
chart around the country especially in
political audiences
i i kind of can see that it's a bit of a
political rorschach test in that about
half of the folks that i show this to
say
well this is great you know this is why
the u.s economy is doing so much better
than everybody else and this is proof
that we should be spending more on
federal stimulus
and then i have about the other half of
the room you can immediately tell is
saying well that's way too much money i
can't believe we spent so much more than
all these other states or all these
other countries
we should really stop spending so this
same chart can be different things to
different people um and they're both
right
mostly because the the u.s has done much
better than a lot of other developed
countries coming out of the recession
as a result of the amount of federal
fiscal stimulus that we've had
the other part of this is that the
amount that we have spent is going to
have and is having additional economic
consequences throughout the u.s economy
and will have it consequences for a
number of years to come
so it doesn't take
we see what's going on with the economy
the economy's done better because of
this fiscal stimulus but it doesn't take
a phd in economics to figure out what
the results of this kind of spending is
if you take seven trillion dollars and
you you are about five and a half
trillion dollars and you shove it
through the u.s economy over a very
short period of time
the the end result is going to be at
least some inflation and we're starting
to see that um in earnest in the last
few quarters
now i want to emphasize again that what
you're seeing here is the pre-invasion
forecast so this is a february forecast
we'll talk a little bit about how this
forecast has changed in a minute but
even even before the uh russian invasion
of ukraine uh we expected to see
inflation stick around for quite a bit
in 2022 so we really didn't get back
down in the pre-invasion forecast to
what we would call relatively normal
levels of inflation you know two and a
half to three percent until the very end
of calendar year 2022
now we did see it coming down pretty
significantly there mostly as a result
as you can see this blue line dark blue
line that's the 10-year treasury yield
that's a result of the federal reserve
raising interest rates and trying to
squeeze some of that excess demand out
of the money markets
and trying to tamp inflation down quite
a bit
the russian invasion of ukraine has
obviously turned this on its head a
little bit
because we've had the realization of two
very significant risks to the economy
over a very short period of time
now the
table that you see here this is what we
kind of call our risk matrix
and what it is it's on the y-axis here
we have the likelihood of some of these
risks coming to fruition
and then on the x-axis we have the
severity of that shock so how important
would that be to the economic outlook
how much damage would it potentially do
to the outlook and you can see that two
of the most damaging and most likely
shocks to the outlook the pre-invasion
outlook have taken place in a very short
period of time
um first of all is a geopolitical event
obviously the the russian invasion of
ukraine um presents some amazing
uncertainty into the economic outlook
and so the shock and the subsequent
sanctions
create that uncertainty for businesses
and households and when there's
uncertainty in the economy markets have
a tendency to have difficulty reacting
to that
but also businesses and households
really have difficulty reacting that and
making long-term economic decisions and
when businesses in economic and
households have trouble making long-term
economic decisions that's a recipe for
much slower most more cautious economic
growth going forward
the other part of this is that the
supply disruptions and the uncertainty
from all the sanctions and from the
actual conflict itself they cause price
pressures to remain in place over a
substantially longer period of time and
i think that's important to talk about
when we look at the new inflation
forecast we don't have inflation
necessarily spiking much higher than we
are currently at but we have prices from
price gains remaining much higher for a
much longer period of time and that can
be just as if not more damaging than
very sharp spikes up in inflation
so what you're seeing here are three
different kind of scenarios for what we
would expect to happen as a result of
the conflict in ukraine
um the first line you're seeing this
blue line that's the february baseline
for the headline
cpi consumer price index
that's akin to the chart that i showed
you earlier and you can see that by the
end of 2022 pre-invasion we had expected
that to get back down into more normal
levels
there are two kind of
scenarios that we think are most likely
here though there are you know almost an
infinite number to calculate at this
point
the green line that you're seeing there
that's what we call a rapid resolution
and by rapid we mean probably six to 12
months we come to some kind of a
cease-fire or a tentative truce in in
ukraine
um where the sanctions maybe stay
most of the sanctions begin to stay in
place for a significant period of time
but
not all of them some of them will come
off
the reason that
we would expect obviously to see much
higher inflation over that time period
is that those sanctions remain in place
some of the the energy and commodity
price increases that we're seeing now
will remain high for some time and so
that leads to much higher inflation for
a longer period of time
when we when all is said and done for
our march forecast this green line is
likely to resemble what our baseline
forecast is or what we would expect is
most likely to happen
remembering that trying to handicap the
outcome of an invasion of a sovereign
country is something that's very
difficult to predict
the orange line that you're seeing here
this is if there's a more lengthy
conflict so this is um the hot war in
ukraine continues for some time
um and sanctions either have to remain
in place or they have to be elevated
even further beyond what they've already
been
imposed not just by the united states
but by the rest of the
most of the rest of the western world
what we would expect under this
situation is for energy prices in
particular to spike over the summer
and energy prices and most commodity
prices to remain relatively high for a
significant period of time
um this is not necessarily the worst
scenario but it's probably the worst
likely scenario
there are obviously so much darker
scenarios that we could go down not just
from an economic standpoint but from a
just a global standpoint
we haven't entertained too many of those
yet through our models but this is
something that would be particularly
damaging to the u.s economy because as
you can see we not only have inflation
sticking around for much longer but we
have it sticking around at a very high
rate so you'd see you know seven percent
plus inflation for the better part of
the year not getting back down to what
we would call a normal range of
inflation until the end of 2023.
that could create a very very difficult
environment for us to operate in
economically because not only would we
have inflation in creeping higher and
higher but we would have a federal
reserve that would have to react to that
higher inflation by potentially slamming
on the brakes a bit harder with terms of
monetary policy so they probably have to
raise interest rates much faster and
they would probably have to raise
interest rates to a much higher point in
order to keep this inflation in check
by doing that when they stop on the
breaks of the economy in order to get
inflation in check they're going to be
slowing overall economic growth
so this is what that translates to in
terms of u.s real gdp growth you can see
we ended 2022 at about four percent gd
or sorry 2021 at about four percent gdp
growth um the blue line again is the
pre-invasion baseline kind of what we
would have expected a slow
cooldown in the pace of economic growth
but still very healthy by historical
standards
the green line which is that rapid
resolution which will again be probably
become our baseline
in march
that has the slowdown
much quicker
into a lower level but still
not necessarily unhealthy by historical
standards and then we would ramp back up
once that rapid resolution kind of
clears up and some of the sanctions
begin to go away
in terms of a lengthy conflict
this there's a lot of uncertainty about
what this would do to gdp growth
but at a minimum it would be a severe
slowdown in the u.s economy possibly
even a recession um
going from five percent to you know less
than one percent growth in um in one
year even if it's not technically a
recession can sure feel like a recession
to the average business or average
household and so
that's a much darker scenario that
hopefully we don't have to go down but
that's kind of the the key to this and
then the worst thing that could happen
is we have this decrease in growth we
have a contraction in the economy at the
same time that we have prices going up
for those of you old enough to remember
that looks a lot like the late 1970s and
the early 1980s in the united states and
it's a term that we call stagflation so
anytime that the us economy is starting
to stagnate we're starting to either
slow significantly or actually contract
and we're seeing prices start to
continue to go up considerably that's
stagflation and it's one of the worst
scenarios that we can we can see from an
economic standpoint
because it does require some very very
um
aggressive action by the federal reserve
which can choke off growth for quite
some time
um so now that i've thoroughly bummed
you all out with those uh slides and
those scenarios i do want to give you
one or two other things to kind of keep
an eye on so that you can gauge kind of
which of these three scenarios we're
kind of finding and what we would need
to get out of this kind of a
forecast
so the the question i'm asked most often
by um by legislators by policy makers is
what can i be keeping an eye on to tell
kind of really
how tight the labor market is where we
are in the economic recovery and without
pause i always tell folks that they
should be watching something called
epoch now epop is kind of a wonky thing
that mostly only economists look at but
uh especially when we're we're looking
at the
labor market that's so unique and so um
unprecedented that we're seeing today it
can be difficult to gauge where we are
in the economic business cycle just by
looking at something like the
unemployment rate the unemployment rate
is 3.8 today however that's not
necessarily a true
picture of the labor market because
we're still missing a lot of people from
the labor market who were part of the
labor market before the pandemic and
have pulled out so what we look at is
e-pop e-pop is the specifically we look
at the prime age epoch which is the
working age population so the number of
people who are employed in the united
states as a share of the number of
people who are age 25 to 54
for those of you who are not 25 to 54 i
promise you i didn't come up with the
name prime age that comes from the bls
there are plenty of prime workers who
are above 54 under 25 i know that but
that's what they look at here so what we
see in the um the data is that any time
that this is the blue line this is all
workers united states anytime this blue
line is above 80 percent
the us is probably in some kind of
really strong economic expansion we
usually can date the top of the business
cycle by how this number peaks out so
you can see in the early 2000s
this peaked out at about 82 percent
we had the 2001 recession this came back
down
we had another very strong business
cycle 2007 this peaked at above 80 and
then we obviously had the great
recession which pulled this way far down
it really took us a really long period
of time um during that the recovery from
the great recession um there's a lot of
people that say the great recession was
followed by the not so great recovery
and you can really see it when you look
at these kind of data
just before the pandemic however at the
end of 2019 is when we started to get
back above 80 percent again
and obviously we saw a huge decline in
primate g-pop as a result of the
pandemic and all of the the business
restrictions that came around the
pandemic
we have since seen that recover quite
significantly and in the last few months
we've seen it really pick up as more and
more states have dropped their business
restrictions we've dropped more masking
requirements and more vaccination
requirements that's allowed some more
people to come off of the sidelines for
various reasons into
the labor market and so now we're seeing
what we would normally assume is a very
late stage recovery and into an economic
expansion so again all else equal you
know take russia out of it for a minute
we see an exceptionally strong labor
market right now probably getting to
about the peak of what we would call
full employment which is why when i
showed you that pre-invasion forecast we
expected um the prime age or sorry the
full employment to occur sometime this
calendar year
those numbers vary a little bit for men
and women i won't get too much into
those details unless somebody has
questions but
the reason i'm bringing this up
especially for new hampshire is that the
labor market in particular and the labor
force is an area that new hampshire
seems to stand out significantly from
the rest of the country as a result of
the the pandemic and i'll show you this
data here
um this is the overall size of the labor
force so these are the number of people
who are working or actively looking for
work in the u.s and in new hampshire and
you can see that they did peak out uh in
the at the beginning or sorry the end of
um and then with the pandemic they they
fell quite precipitously
when we look at this data and i've
indexed this to february 2020 so the the
number 100 would be equal to the level
that they were at just before the
pandemic began
and what i want to point your attention
to most is this kind of last six to nine
months here in 2021 where the u.s labor
market is our labor force has continued
to steadily recover and more people have
flowed into the labor market but in new
hampshire the labor force numbers have
actually fallen off quite a bit after
being relatively flat since the
beginning of the initial recovery um
that's uh something that's unusual
that's not something we're seeing in a
lot of states um and there are a number
of idiosyncratic reasons that that could
be happening
in terms of people you know working
across state lines in terms of people
working multiple jobs because if i look
at the overall number of jobs in new
hampshire they are approaching their
pre-recession or pre-pandemic level so
there's some very unique things going on
here with the labor market and it's
something that's going to be very
important to keep an eye on as new
hampshire's recovery kind of progresses
out into the future so
with that mr chairman i will stop and
pause for questions uh i'd be happy to
answer any questions about this or
anything that i didn't cover that maybe
the committee would love to hear more
about it
questions
representative ames followed by
representative aaron
thank you and thank you for that
excellent presentation
um
this is my question you have a chart uh
i think it's the fifth one
showing the the levels of fiscal support
um by country and the united states is
way above the others
and then you have a series of
of uh charts that relate to inflation in
the united states so my question is how
has inflation played out
in these other countries that had
lower levels of fiscal support
uh mr chairman that
that's a wonderful question
um we are seeing in the
in the developed countries the developed
world which would be pretty much
everybody on this chart
we have seen increased inflation kind of
everywhere and so that's to say that
increased federal fiscal stimulus is not
the sole cause of inflation in the
united states or globally right now
but it is a bit more acute in the united
states over the last several months
especially um and so some of that could
be attributable to
the fact that we've increased fiscal
stimulus more than the average country
but again there are so many other things
to keep in mind there in terms of supply
constraints
and especially around the forecast for
inflation a lot of that is a supply
issue it's not necessarily a demand
issue but when you have inflation it's
where you have
basically there's a there's a mismatch
between the amount of supply and demand
in the economy that can either come from
having way too much demand or it can
have come from having not enough supply
up until this point it's kind of been a
mix we've had a lot more demand than we
were able to supply
but going forward especially because of
the sanctions or because of the invasion
of ukraine
a lot of that will be because of supply
is just not able to ramp up as quickly
as demand is willing to do and so
there's plenty of blame to go around in
that but it's certainly been significant
in the united states
thank you before we go to the next
question i do have a question on that
same
figure five
is
how about russia we see china on there
but
how did russia participate in fiscal
support mr chairman russia did provide
some token fiscal support but to be
honest because of the sanctions that
have been leveled on russia since 2014
when they first invaded crimea and
ukraine
russia has been an almost constant
state of
either economic recession or economic
stagnation their economy has really been
hurting over the last five or six years
and so they really were not in as good
of shape as us in their ability to
borrow to finance some of these stimulus
programs
the other thing is we've noticed uh and
it's difficult to get a lot of
transparency into some of the things
that they have done around the pandemic
they also were not as
strict in terms of their lockdowns or
mass mandates in russia at least that we
can tell
as most of europe and the united states
thank you representative aaron
thank you mr chair
and thank you mr white for your
presentation
so i'm looking at the chart for
realization of risks
and while um
you know under inflation you you
mentioned supply disruptions and
uncertainty but
wouldn't supply chain disruptions and
unability unavailability of products be
sort of its own
category of risks that should be in this
chart
uh representative mr chairman um
it
the the reason that it's included under
inflation is that the the net result of
that would be
inflation very because there's two
different parts of the supply disruption
there are we've had some
supply disruptions up to this point
already as a result of the pandemic and
those are baked into our baseline
forecast so we wouldn't necessarily say
that's a risk to the forecast because
it's it's assumed in there
the the risks that we're talking about
here are things that weren't assumed in
the pre-invasion forecast but now are
and that is a lot of those supply
disruptions especially around certain
commodities
precious metals
a lot of gases and and natural resources
that are used in the industrial
processes um we're not able to get those
out of russia or ukraine or that part of
the world and so there's a major
additional supply disruption on top of
what we're already seeing if that makes
sense
okay thank you for that
uh representative romney followed by
representative wiley
thank you mr chair thank you mr white
um
let's talk about chips for a minute uh
computer chips
um
that's that's a real problem i mean one
of our largest commodities that most
people buy are cars
and if you go buy any dealership the
lots are pretty much vacant right now
uh my understanding is that intel is
looking at building a new large plant in
ohio
that would help but that's going to be
probably a couple years away
in terms of that so
i mean
how do economists start looking at a
chip shortages i guess the rest of the
world is developing at a at a fast pace
as well
uh putting a demand on chips but um
what is your what is your outlook in
terms of of that production being
increased to meet demand representative
mr chairman i'm glad you brought that up
that's actually one of the most
significant supply disruptions that
we're facing not just in the united
states but globally um and the the
incident or the incident the invasion of
ukraine
has made that actually worse one of the
anecdotes we found out yesterday i was
just talking about
some of the
precious metals and supplies that are
used in industrial processes
one of the things
one of the key inputs to chip production
is actually neon gas and the type of
neon gas that's used in chip production
the united states i believe i just found
this out yesterday about 90 percent of
the gas the neon gas that we use in our
chip production comes from ukraine and
russia
um it's a by-product of their their
their steel producing
activities um that is gonna be um that's
just one of the many different
connections that we have with that part
of the world in terms of our industrial
production and the supply disruptions
that are likely to take place as a
result of these new risks that have been
realized in the forecast
when we look at the forecast in terms of
the impacts that these kind of
disruptions will have
the first place we look is all of the
different goods that those ships are
used into automobiles being the most
important from an inflationary
standpoint one of the reasons that the
pre-invasion forecast had such a
staying power in terms of inflation was
because of
very advanced computer goods especially
automobiles
really increasing in price and those
supply constraints not being lifted very
quickly you know we're doing all i can
we can in the united states you know you
mentioned the intel planet ohio to try
and domesticize some of that production
really from an inflationary standpoint
but also from a national security
standpoint
but that's going to take time to do you
don't just you know build a chip plan
overnight it's going to take several
years and even once that's built out
it's going to take several years to do
that um the the upside to that if there
is any is that we are seeing the the car
industry the automobile industry doing a
really great job of trying to adapt to a
world with fewer chips um and so
companies are going to do that they're
going to adapt they're going to find
ways around that but in the meantime as
we saw those forecasts there's going to
be some really sticky prices and there's
going to be some really
high uncertainty in terms of consumer
spending consumer prices
and overall business activity the the
flip side of that again the one of the
things that makes us feel a little bit
better about that from a consumer
spending standpoint is that there is a
tremendous amount of pent up demand pen
up cash out there that will help cushion
the blow it's not going to make it okay
but it's going to make it a lot less
painful than it would have been
otherwise if we were in a different part
of the business cycle
thank you
representative weiler
thank you mr chairman and mr white
i was listening to
a
report about
the threat of russia to the u.s and the
point was made
that the us gdp
is 20 times greater than the russian gdp
i wonder if you could tell me what the
gdp in china or any other country is
anywhere near
the gdp of the u.s representative mr
chairman that's correct so the gdp in
the u.s is about 22 trillion dollars and
i'm speaking in rough numbers here
um the russian gdp at least before the
invasion was somewhere between one and a
half and two trillion dollars a year
just to give you some order magnitude
we are the largest gdp in the world and
i i could look it up for you china is
number two in the world so they're the
second largest economy in the world
i'd have to look it up but i believe the
last i saw they were somewhere around 15
trillion dollars
thank you thank you mr chairman
representative
you mr chairman uh
i wanted to ask about the supply chain
and why you think it's more of a problem
for the united states is that only
because of the chip market
i'm sorry representative could you
repeat that question
yeah on
you'd
the way you'd been talking about uh the
supply chain it sounded like it was a
greater problem for the united states
than for the other countries that
we look at
and on is that only because of the chip
supply problem or what else are we
having more problems than anybody else
with uh supply representative madam
chair i think the
it's not necessarily significantly worse
in the united states than it is in other
developed countries like the uk or
canada or some of those other countries
but i think it does hit us a bit harder
mostly because we are a net importer in
the united states so we we consume a lot
more goods than we produce in the united
states and so we are much more reliant
on goods that are produced overseas in
terms of driving our economy um so if
your economy um like china for example
that actually exports more than it
imports right then you are not going to
be as impacted by supply chain
disruptions as you would be if you are
a country that does the opposite like
the united states
representative aaron
thank you mr chair
thank you again mr white i
uh
i represent a rural rural communities
and i'm already hearing from many of the
farmers in my district
that
the costs
for
their supplies as they start to think
about you know spring planting
especially fertilizer that many of the
costs of these items are
have gone sky high
and
so being that the cost for our farmers
has gone up
i'm concerned about our food production
as and and resulting food prices
as a result of the increases of the cost
to our farmers
some farmers may not even continue
growing their crops because it just
doesn't pay for them
and i wonder if you can comment on the
cost
of
inflation for
food and and how that will impact our
economy and our families who are
struggling
with the incomes that they have
representative uh mr chairman
there
the agricultural industry is going to be
one of the industries that is most
impacted not just by the existing the
kind of the pre-invasion outlook that we
had for prices but also for
um the
the invasion of ukraine um there's kind
of two pieces so before you know setting
russia and ukraine aside um some of the
the areas that we're seeing the biggest
price increases going back to
semiconductors uh and some of the steels
and other raw materials that are used um
to make agricultural products um so the
machinery all the farm machinery is
going to go up significantly in price
the same similar to what automobiles are
doing um but then all the fertilizers a
lot of that things they're going to
continue to go up for some time
it's going to depend a lot there's going
to be a lot of differentiation across
you know different crop types and in
livestock versus versus crop
agriculture
but there there's going to be a lot of
differentiation and a lot of pain in
terms of price increases in the
agricultural sector
in terms of the the way that the
invasion of ukraine kind of layers over
on top of that
again we'll probably create additional
differentiation in terms of winners and
losers within the agricultural industry
itself
for a number of reasons first of all the
prices for all of those things are going
to continue to go up even further so a
lot of those inputs are going to go up
we talked about you know the neon gas
for semiconductors but there's a lot of
steel there's a lot of other parts of
raw materials that go into the
industrial mix that create farm
machinery and farm inputs
that will continue to go up in price
the the offset to that though is
especially for wheat in particular
agricultural commodity prices are going
to go up considerably and they already
are going up considering the wheat
prices um you know
there is so much and i can't remember
the exact statistics but a large
majority of the world's wheat comes from
ukraine and russia and so if ukraine is
not producing wheat um it would be the
same as like taking saudi arabia out of
oil production right taking the ukraine
out of wheat production has huge impacts
for the rest of the world's markets um
and so wheat prices in particular are
going to go up so even if you're not in
agriculture you're going to experience
the pain of higher food prices as a
result of wheat prices going up pretty
considerably in the next several months
again barring a hopefully a quick
resolution in in the ukraine conflict
yeah i do
so then
mr white how do you see
that
inflationary
pressure
impacting new hampshire in particular
madam chair representative or sorry
representative
mr chair
the
new hampshire is going to be probably a
bit more impacted than the rest of the
us for a couple of reasons first of all
is you know the the footprint of
agriculture in new hampshire um but i
think the the bigger um
impact will be the fact that new
hampshire hampshire's in the northeast
most of new hampshire's trading partners
global trading partners are in europe
europe is being out
is being hit by an outsize impact from
the ukraine conflict so as the european
economy starts to
start a little bit as a result of this
conflict a lot of the trading partners
for new hampshire firms are going to be
having trouble as well
and so it's not going to be
significantly more than the average
impact in terms of the united states but
it certainly will be higher than average
senator rosenwald
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
white
your slide on labor force recovery
shows that around the middle of last
year
the lines crossed and new hampshire is
now lagging
the rest of the country
in terms of labor force recovery i'm
wondering if you could comment on what
factors you think might
be leading to that
uh madam
representative mr chair i think um
there's a couple things here and i would
i would encourage you to ask questions
from the the folks who are going to
follow me about this because they may
have some more informed opinions having
watched the new hampshire data much more
closely than i have
um the the easiest and hopefully
hopefully most
hopefully what we would expect to happen
here is that hopefully the data is just
wrong this is monthly data that comes
from the the bls
sometimes it's revised and so what we
would hope is that that's just a bad
reading and it's not really true right
but more likely what we are going to see
is
that there are a number of changes or
especially around remote work that could
be having an impact on this given where
new hampshire is located and given that
there are a lot of commuters that go
across the border to to massachusetts
and other states
that there are some counting issues
where the total number of jobs is still
relatively the same
but the people are are maybe living on
another
side of the state line than they have
previously
the other thing that could be causing
this is especially in lower income
households you could have lower income
households who are leaving the state but
the households who are remaining are
working multiple jobs which is why you
see a discrepancy between the um
the household
survey and the
payroll survey
but the the most concerning thing the
thing that would worry me most about
this is that this is indicative of more
people potentially leaving new hampshire
altogether so oftentimes when we see
data like this what is indicative of and
we just don't have enough data to
confirm this yet is it's indicative of
of people leaving the state for other
states um for their workforce and we're
seeing this in some other northeastern
states we've been seeing it for a while
and for example connecticut or new york
pennsylvania where i live
um
play people eventually moving the state
and leaving the state either because the
costs are high or because there's more
dynamic labor forces elsewhere or
because their population is aging and
more people are retiring to to warmer
states
there's a number of reasons that could
cause that but if i were looking at this
and exploring in more detail that is the
the possibility that would scare me the
most
representative tunisian
thank you mr chairman
and uh thank you um
mr white for the presentation um
one one area that we know has been um
becoming increasingly difficult is
energy costs
barrel of oil being
the uh thing that's really set off
all sorts of um
whether it's you know propane or cost of
gasoline and so forth anyways that that
cost has been going up prior to ukraine
and obviously with the russian invasion
uh things are getting much worse very
quickly
i heard a report this morning that
if the current administration signaled
that
u.s
you know a willingness to increase u.s
production
futures markets would quickly
cause oil prices to start dropping
have you done any analysis that and
given the pressures
on on the administration to start
increasing domestic production
if that happens have you done any
analysis on how that could help
inflation
or
energy prices in general representative
mr chairman absolutely we have
and there
it's interesting because when we look
around at
the u.s producers are really the swing
producers globally now they have been
for some time
um especially because we have a lot more
shale oil than we used to it's a lot
easier to turn the taps on and turn the
taps off
quickly
however the capacity that we have in the
united states is not to the same degree
it doesn't match up very well to all of
the untapped capacity that's overseas
already there's a there's a tremendous
amount of excess capacity already in
some of the largest oil producing
regions in the country are of the world
um saudi arabia for example they could
turn on the taps and pump two million
more barrels a million barrels of world
per day um tomorrow if they wanted to
not necessarily tomorrow but in the next
couple weeks
um
iran still has a bunch of oil they
haven't brought on the market um
uh the uae has a tremendous amount of
world that the capacity they could turn
back on that are much more significant
than what we would be able to turn on in
the united states um and so
any of if any of those countries decided
or opec in general decided to
turn the taps back on to do that
they could definitely equilibrate
equilibrate prices much more quickly
than what we're seeing
but i think the reason that most
producers and you could argue that u.s
producers aren't doing this either is
they're waiting to see kind of how long
this disruption is going to last is
russian production going to be taken off
for a significant period of time
or is it just causing displacement
within the market we know that russia
usually sells i think about 5
million barrels of oil per day
about half of that goes to europe
and another significant chunk of it goes
to china
china has showed that they're going to
continue to buy they're trying to stay
out of it it seems but they're they're
continuing to buy russian oil with no
problem and they're actually buying at a
huge discount right now because very few
other people will buy russian oil so
russia is going to continue to sell
their oil and
a lot of europe is still buying their
energy from russia and so the the point
is if we turned on capacity in the u.s
it probably wouldn't have much of an
impact in terms of overall prices it
would be
sending some some signals in terms of
sentiment but it wouldn't have
necessarily a huge impact on the
the interplay between supply and demand
globally over the next few months
follow-up
um
okay so in a in a longer shorter term
um it may not
help immediately but longer term if i if
i think back to say a year and a half
ago
when the u.s was the largest uh
exporter or largest producer
prices were staying down so
i guess you know in a longer term
scenario it seems like it would help
longer term keep prices down because now
these other exporters have to compete
with u.s prices representative mr
chairman i think longer term you know
the more energy dependent independent
the united states is the better off
things are for the united states um but
there's a lot of other really big
producers out there in terms of the
overall supply and demand i don't know
that it would have too much of an impact
on prices i think a lot of what we're
seeing in prices right now is a result
of just uncertainty over the
invasion of ukraine
but to your point um the more
supply that the u.s can bring to bear on
the global economy the more control
and more certainty that we will have
around energy prices
thank you
mr white you've done a great job on your
presentation and answering questions i
have one more question
a new event happened last night
in that the russians took over the nuke
the largest nuclear facility
in europe
which is located in ukraine
if they shut that down have you done an
analysis of what that will do
to
everything that you talked about
well mr chairman thank you for saving
the easiest question for the end
um
there's um
we have not done a an active um
uh research on it but what we know just
anecdotally again we're still finding
out a lot of the news that came out last
night from what we understand is there
were only two of the reactors that were
still functioning at the at the power
plant
um so if they just shut it down and it's
no longer able to produce power
we don't see that as a huge um economic
cost outside of ukraine itself um they
that power plant i don't believe was
exporting power to any other countries
around europe
but to your point
the potential escalation of this
conflict beyond
you know what it is today which is
horrific enough as it is but the
potential
escalation of that beyond what it is
creates some economic um scenarios that
are much darker than the ones that i
showed you here today and so um it's a
it's a very scary time
period but it's a very scary time
economically and the the odds of
something going wrong that pushes us
into a recession or into something
that's much
scarier than a recession are much higher
today
than they've been for some time
thank you
any further questions from
either
committee
saying thank you again
mr white
for agreeing to do this for us thank you
so much for having me thank you thank
you so much for having me
uh
we're right on time because it's one
minute to 10
and the presenter
10 o'clock is is already here
just wait one minute
jennifer are we all set to go
thank you
i've been 10 o'clock
uh and phil are you all set to go
i think so yes i'm going to make sure
that i can advance these slides smoothly
okay i'll wait until you check that and
then i'll introduce you
you may have to bear with me if i have
to scroll through them but i'm happy to
start
okay
this is phil slutten from the new
hampshire fiscal policy institute
and phil
is going to talk to us
on the state economic conditions and
economic forecasts
phil slatten is a senior policy
analyst at the new hampshire fiscal
policy institute
where he has worked for more than five
years he conducts research and analysis
on the state budget
state revenues and expenditures
and the economy and economic security of
granite staters
with a focus on those with low and
moderate income
he previously served for three years as
a performance auditor for the new
hampshire office of legislative budget
assistance
he was born and raised in new hampshire
filled earned a bachelor's degree from
grinnell college in iowa and holds a
masters of public affairs from the
college
from the university of wisconsin
he is also a graduate of leadership new
hampshire from the class of 2018.
phil was recognized as one of the new
hampshire's union leaders 40 under 40
in 2021
and was named the 2020 young
professional of the year by the greater
concord chamber of commerce
so phil it's all yours
thank you very much chairman major and
thank you all for the opportunity to
speak uh with you this morning um i have
quite a few slides so i'm going to go
through them relatively quickly but if
you do have a at the chairman's
discretion too if you do have a quick
technical question about a slide i'm
happy to take it as we go along um
really i'm hoping that this will also be
a reference for you as you go forward
you can consult this slide deck
again and i'm happy to of course take
questions afterwards and i'll stick
around through the lunch hour as well if
anyone has any questions um after
after the subsequent presentation
so um what i'll do here is i'll start
with uh the slide that you'll also see
at the end of the presentation this is a
quick summary of the takeaways that um
that the this presentation will discuss
and you'll see some of the
some of the data that tell this story um
in in overview the economy has uh has
recovered from sort of the early points
of the earliest points of the coven 19
crisis but the recovery has not been
complete we're not back to the trend
line that we would have expected it
hadn't happened yet i mean it has been
uneven it hasn't been
it hasn't reached everyone evenly in the
state
federal assistance has provided
significant economic stimulus that's a
key part of the reason why we saw the
level of growth that we did in the
second half of 2020 and throughout 2021
but there are workforce constraints on
the new hampshire economy and those
workforce constraints are driven in part
by some of the some of the continuing
health effects of the pandemic and
the
and the limitations that we see in terms
of access to child care as well as some
of the long-term demographic trends that
the state would have been facing anyway
even if there hadn't been a pandemic
there was already some discussion of
inflation i'll mention it here that
inflation is a risk for the economy
going forward including in new hampshire
and it's in part due to the rapid
changes that we've seen in spending on
goods and services it's been hard for
private sector markets to adjust and
what happens on that front going forward
has implications for the hampton new
hampshire economy and the economy as a
whole as well as inflation uh
but the
the household budgets in new hampshire
that we've household incomes in new
hampshire have been outpaced by
inflation through 2021 at least based on
preliminary data and that also has
implications for people's spending power
and there are significant opportunities
for the state to help build an equitable
inclusive recovery going forward
particularly with the available federal
resources
now i've broken this presentation into
three parts parts one and three are much
shorter than part two but the first part
is just looking at sort of general
economic conditions and a quick overview
of what we see in the new hampshire
economy right now
so the graph that you see on slide four
has two lines on it the one that is
green or in the squares
that is gross state product so it's our
own state level version of gdp gross
national gross domestic product and you
can see that it is not back up to trend
line it's not back to where we would
have expected it to be
if there hadn't been a pandemic that you
can see the the downward spike if you
will in the second quarter of 2020 but
it's a about back up to where it was
prior to that right at the end of 2019
and uh and that you know that suggests
that a significant portion of the
economy at least in terms of this gross
state product measure has recovered but
if you look at the other line which is
employment in the state average
quarterly employment in this state we
haven't seen that come back to those
pre-pandemic levels yet and again both
are below the trend line that we would
have expected again if there hadn't been
a pandemic
i'll note that these numbers do get
revised so if you were to look at gross
state product in six months or a year it
might look a little bit different
but these are the best data that we have
at this time for that measure
we can break that measure down by
industry so what you see on page five is
the breakdown of gross state product by
the by industry and the contributions of
each industry to grow state product
specifically how they've changed in the
second third quarters of 2021 relative
to those two middle quarters in 2019 so
what industries have grown since then in
their gross state product contribution
and which have fallen behind you can see
all the way over on the left real estate
rental and leasing retail trade
which includes online services as well
management of companies is a relatively
small industry but has seen growth
administrative support services
wholesale trade information
transportation warehousing utilities
construction and accommodation and food
services even on the positive side of
the ledger on the other side you can see
arts and entertainment and recreation is
still quite a bit lower again in the
middle two quarters of 2021 relative to
those middle two quarters of 2019
so that's contributions to gross state
product but what about
the shifts in employment how has
employment changed and you can see that
on slide six um this is measuring two
different items one is the change in
employment by industry this isn't every
industry but this is most of them
in employment comparing the preliminary
estimates that we have for december 2021
to what we saw as measures the same
measure of employment in december 2019
that's that solid bar or the green one
if you're looking at the color version
and in the cross hatch bar or the blue
one what's the change since 2020 and if
we look at the change at on the left
side of the graph we can see that
manufacturing for example is still well
below where it was in 20 in december
2019 it's a little bit higher than it
was in december of 2020 so suggest some
recovery but there's still a ways to go
education services um healthcare and
social assistance we see a similar story
retail trade is down by both measures
and then accommodation food services
we've seen quite a bit of recovery from
december of 2020 but it's still below
where it was in december of 2019.
if you look all the way over on the
right side we can see sort of double
positives if you will in professional
scientific and technical services and
then transportation warehousing and
utilities
so that's a picture of where the job
recovery is in terms of industry
but what about geography
if you take a look at slide seven this
is total jobs broken up by county and
this is comparing the average employment
based in the county in the first three
quarters of 19 of 2019 to the first
three quarters of 2021.
and one thing that's interesting here is
there's not necessarily a clear
sort of rural urban pattern there's not
necessarily a clear pattern in terms of
region of the state there may be some
patterns by industry but you know for
example
if you look at carroll county and coast
county those saw the biggest percentage
declines which is the cross thatch bar
you those are the biggest percentage
declines in the number of jobs uh in
this three quarters of 2021 relative to
2019.
of course the the number is relatively
small compared to for example
hillsborough and rockingham counties
but
it's still a larger percentage decline
in those areas so that might be you know
recreation accommodation and food
services those we could see that those
industries may be more important in
those counties
in terms of employment however if you
look at some other rural counties in the
state or more rural counties in the
state sullivan cheshire county for
example we see some of the smallest
percentage declines
and then hillsborough belknap grafton or
sort of in the middle if you will so
there's not a clear pattern on that
front but what is clear is that there's
still
at least based on these data there's
still job recovery to be had in every
county in the state
so i'll move on to the second part of
the presentation and what i've tried to
do would you take your question yes
absolutely representative yeah thank you
good seeing you again nice to see you as
well um this is a silly question i and
greg on on five when we say mining
quarrying oil gas obviously we have no
oil or gas extraction so mining must be
uh granite
uh granite mining would fall under this
yes um and this is this is a very small
industry right relative to some of the
other industries that you see on this
graph so this this is a complete picture
i didn't i included every industry on
here if i recall correctly that one a
small percentage change is not a big
number of jobs and not as big a gross
state product contribution as as some of
these other ones again it's a percentage
change but pretty much grant i can't
think of anything else we quarry i i
can't think of anything else either but
i'm sure
knowledge around the table would help
yeah okay gravel i guess yeah there we
go
thank you phil
i'm pete on slide number four can you
tell me how the
average quarterly in
employment would compare to a
pre-pandemic graph of the same
of the projection anyways yeah that's a
great question and i think we'll we'll
get to some of that in part two of the
presentation um but i think that what we
see here is something that may be
somewhat lower than we would have seen
before
but the num the the pre-pandemic
employment was on an upward trajectory
after having been um at least the size
of the labor force having been
relatively stagnant for some time so
the i think that's a key question the
question is here whether the pandemic
has accelerated trends that would have
already been happening in which case it
would have been a little bit higher or
if the pandemic has led to more
fundamental shifts in the economy that
have resulted in lower employment
and i think it's probably the former i
think that we may have seen employment
be a little bit higher than it is now
but it's not as though we would have
seen a massive upward trajectory that is
still a lot lower so we'll talk about
that a little bit more in in subsequent
slides but i hope that i hope that makes
sense and addresses your question
yes thank you
go ahead and continue okay thank you
very much
so um in part two of the presentation
what i'd like to do is is hold myself
accountable a little bit because at the
end of uh january 2021 i had the opera
in january 2021 i had the opportunity to
present to the house and senate ways and
means committees and at the end of that
presentation i asked a series of
questions about
that the answers of those would help
inform what the economy looks like in
the future um and in posing those
questions to you um i thought that it
was fair to me for me to go back and try
to answer those questions as best as i
could a year later with the available
information that we have
so
you'll see on slide nine these are the
questions that i posed at the end of
that 2021 presentation
exactly as i uh posed them to you
with a different title on the slide and
i'm going to go through each of them not
exactly in this order but i'm going to
go through each of them and try my best
to answer them
in part two
so first
will workers be able to rejoin the
workforce efficiently and this is key
question then obviously a key question
now and gets a little bit to what some
of senator hennessey had just asked
about
so you can see on slide 11 this is a
graph of the not seasonally adjusted
size of the workforce in new hampshire
and note that it does start at 500 000
so the graph axis doesn't start at zero
um and and you can see the uh total
number of people who are employed on a
monthly basis based on these estimates
in the solid bar and then the cross that
shows the number of people who are
officially recognized as unemployed
they're they're actively seeking work
but they don't have a job
and you can see that we are still below
our pre-pandemic peak our pre-pandemic
peak again not seasonally adjusted was
july of 2019
and i believe i'm remembering correctly
the january 2022 data are about 28 000
fewer people in the workforce than that
july figure of course if this were
comparing july to july i might be a
little bit more concerned by that drop
than i am but that's still noteworthy
that we are not back in terms of the
size of the labor force in new hampshire
to those pre-pandemic levels
now
that is likely part of a long-term
decline
but that long-term decline was probably
accelerated by the pandemic so if you
look on slide 12 you can see that there
are two lines one is the line that has
the two um sidebar lines on either side
of it that is the actual size of the
labor force and uh that
that actual size of labor force in terms
of the number of people participating in
new hampshire's labor force um you can
see that over the last and this is uh
this graph shows 2000 to 2021 on a
12-month rolling average
if you look at just before the great
recession so 2006 2007 the labor force
size stayed relatively consistent over
roughly a 10-year period following that
again on a 12-month rolling average
basis and it wasn't until we really
started to see the economy heat up and
the unemployment rate in new hampshire
had fallen below 3 percent for some time
that we saw the size of the labor force
actually start to increase and you can
see that in the data for 2017
2019 on this graph and then the pandemic
hits and you see that line turn back
down and appear to be a little bit lower
now than where it was before for that
long period of time
the solid line on the graph shows the
labor force participation rate so this
is measuring
basically
relative to population what has happened
to the size of the labor force and the
labor force participation rate has been
in a long-term decline and that
long-term decline appeared to maybe
stall when we were in that um a hotter
job market leading up to the pandemic
but the pandemic has turned it down and
you can see again that 12 month rolling
average suggests that we're below maybe
where the trend line would have
been so why is the labor force smaller
than it was before what insights can we
gain from available data as to why the
labor force may be smaller in new
hampshire you can see on slide 13 that
this is the labor force participation
rate comparing 2019 to 2021 so what's
the change over those two
across those two years
and looking at the labor force
participation rate by age group and you
can see that for most every age group
the labor force participation rate is
lower i'll note if you look at different
time periods these data do fluctuate
especially in the ends right for the
groups that are not as large a part of
the labor force so that 75 and over age
group the 16 to 19 those vary a little
bit more depending on the time period
that you're looking at
but i want to draw your attention to two
uh two specific portions of the
population one is the younger workers
particularly those workers aged 20 to 34
or specifically age age 25 to 34 we see
that 3.1 percent drop and then somewhat
older workers those aged 55 to 74 where
we see that 3.5 drop
so let's talk about that second group
first
if we look at data from the current
population survey which asks people in
part about their employment status one
of the questions that one of the one of
the answers that you can get to those
questions in that survey
is
that someone says they do not want a job
right they're not looking for work
because they do not want a job right now
what you see on slide 14 is the number
of people
who are um age 16 to 24 age 25 to 54 or
age 55 years and older who are
indicating that they do not want a job
and that's why they're not in the labor
force
and the across the three years 2019 2020
and 2021 that you can see represented by
these bars the 16 to 24 age group and
the 25 to 34 age group is pretty
consistent but we can see the 55 years
and older age group across these three
years again as we enter the pandemic and
we're solidly inside the pandemic in
we can see that that number has
increased right so that's probably where
we're losing a significant portion of
the labor force again people entering
traditional retirement age this is not
necessarily a surprise but there may
also be some health factors associated
with people saying i'm potentially more
at risk than other age groups i'm going
to take myself out of the labor force
over the course of the pandemic so we
don't know how much of this is temporary
and how much is permanent for example
if you look on slide 15
you can see the age distribution the
estimated age distribution based on 2019
data
for the age demographics in the state
where is the population relative to
their ages and you can see there are two
peaks there's roughly the 20 to 29 age
group is one peak and then roughly 50 to
64. and remember this is 2019 estimates
unfortunately we don't have the 2020
census data at this granular level yet
but uh everyone's probably about three
years older right
now and you can see here that if we look
at we do have this peak that is in that
50 to 64 age group if you compare these
2019 data to 2010 which i do on the next
two slides you can see that relative to
2010 about 109 000 more people are age
55 and older and about 74 000 more
people are age 65 and older so again
there are some long-term demographics at
play here that you don't necessarily see
to this level at the national economy
that likely answer a significant part of
this question around what has happened
to the labor force and what has been
happening to the labor force in new
hampshire
now let's talk a little bit about the
younger end of the spectrum what may be
happening particularly with those 25 to
34 age group
one of the things that we've seen as a
result of the pandemic is the u.s census
bureau has started conducting what's
called the household pulse survey
fortunately we didn't have these data
before the pandemic but it is a
more of a week on week or a short number
of weeks in terms of a turnaround for
when are we getting data that asks a
bunch of questions of survey respondents
including about their employment status
and if they aren't working what are
their reasons for not working so they
have a series of options to pick from
about half the people that responded to
the survey in new hampshire and said
they weren't working and we're looking
at the time period here of
i've aggregated july to the most recent
data in february to sort of give us a
little bit more of a solid picture as
opposed to a lot of variability from
week to week
we about half the people in new
hampshire said i'm not working because
i'm retired right so half the people who
said they weren't working gave that
reason
so
this graph doesn't show those folks who
said i'm not working because i'm retired
if you and doesn't show the folks who
gave an uncategorized reason but if you
look at the categorized reasons
the top reason was because someone said
they were sick or they had a disability
and they were not working as a as a
result the next most common reason was
someone said i or that adults identified
was that they were caring for children
not in school or in daycare
so
a lot of people who aren't working are
saying you know you know five or six
percent of the people who aren't working
and that 506 percent includes the pool
of folks who are retired
said they were not working because they
were caring for children who weren't who
didn't have care otherwise right and
this is this is saying people who are
not working period not people who are
for example scaling back their hours or
splitting their time differently
um the third reason is uh and again we
don't have a pre-pandemic baseline but
the third reason the third most common
reason was i did not want to be employed
at this time
the fourth was there was caring for
someone who was sick with covet 19 or
they had symptoms themselves
that they were laid off or furloughed
during the pandemic was the next reason
that they were concerned about getting
or spreading the coronavirus or that
they were caring for an older adult so
that rounds out sort of the top reasons
that we can see here again based on
these data
um yes i see you uh representative braun
abramdi
so
where would uh
parents who decide that one of the
parents that's going to stay home and
uh raise the kids
right so um and this is how where we're
at the mercy of how an uh an individual
decides based on the categories that
available to respond to the question so
um it could be that it would probably be
where the the caring for children
category but it could be that someone
said
well it's not that i'm caring for
children because they're not in school
or daycare so i'm just going to say for
example i don't want to be employed at
this time right because i'm caring for
children but i'm not not being employed
because they were because they would
otherwise be in daycare or in school and
that's not available right so we are
stuck with some of the nuances
unfortunately of how people may have
responded to this individually but i
hope that addresses your question
representative
you're welcome
okay great thank you
so let's move on to the next question um
will employment income losses and there
were there was quite a bit of employment
income loss especially in 2020
lead to a more sort of regular looking
recession if you will
or the will the recovery happen more
quickly
and we've seen that especially um
especially given some of the information
that we even saw in the last
presentation that those employment
income losses were
don't appear to have be something that
is slowing down the economy right now
they could still be a significant
component of it particularly for lower
income workers but
what we're seeing is that you know the
employment growth constraints are
less associated with income losses in
2020 or ongoing income losses and appear
to be more associated with um
with some of these other factors so the
graph on page 20 shows two different
measures of employment
one is a monthly survey a more a rapidly
produced monthly survey and one is a
count based on the unemployment
compensation system
counts and we can see that there's you
know there's been a slowing in
employment growth over this time period
and you know
that that is that is something that was
workforce constraints which we'll talk
about a little we've already talked
about some we'll talk about a little bit
more is definitely a risk to the economy
going forward um on slide 21 i wanted to
address and you already had a great
discussion about inflation so i'm not
going to talk about it very much here
but i did want to address inflation a
little bit in terms of the
risk to the economy going forward in new
hampshire
one of the things that gives me a little
bit more confidence that what we're
seeing is temporary is just how much of
a shift there has been in expenditures
like household expenditures so this is a
measure of personal consumption
expenditures in the united states these
are these aren't new hampshire data on
slide 21
you can see that overall personal
consumption expenditures may be back to
where they were on trend line relative
to these are all relative to the last
quarter of 2019
but we've seen a really significant
shift in what people are spending money
on
and that's hard for markets to keep up
with right when we're talking about
services being quite a bit lower but
goods particularly durable goods being
20 percent higher at the end of last
year and even close to 30 percent in the
middle of last year that's a really
significant shift that is difficult as
is going to feed into these supply chain
bottlenecks and feed into the inflation
that we've seen
this also has long-term implications not
just for inflation what does the economy
look like after the pandemic is this
shift to goods a little bit more
permanent or do we see services catch
back up
as as hopefully we see fewer covet 19
variants
causing disruptions to
what the econ relative to what the
economy looked like prior to the
pandemic
now we don't unfortunately have data at
that level at detail for new hampshire
itself um but you can see on slide 22
comparing 2019 to 2020 and those same
personal consumption expenditures you
can see that services were quite a bit
lower in 2020 than they were in 2019 on
a per capita basis
expenditures on a per capita basis
whereas for goods they went up so
hopefully we'll get more data and
understand the picture more in new
hampshire when we get to when we get
those 2021 data but we don't have them
yet
now one cost i want to mention in
particular
that is
that is a significant economic headwind
in new hampshire is housing and the
housing supply and you'll hear more
about housing from people who know more
about it than i do in the afternoon
but the housing supply is very
constrained in the state and has become
dramatically more constrained than even
its pre-pandemic constrained status
over the course of over the course of
the last few years
what you can see on slide 23 is the in
the solid lines with triangles and
squares respectively the median home
sale prices or for single family homes
and for condos and both have gone up
quite dramatically i mean for the this
is a 12-month rolling average but
comparing 2018 to
the latest data from january 2022 we can
see that on a month rolling average the
median home sale price has gone up from
maybe about 280 thousand dollars to
nearly 400 thousand dollars whereas
previously we only saw 400 thousand
dollar median home sale prices in for
example rockingham county now that's the
statewide figure
and if you look at the two dashed lines
or the dashed and dotted lines those are
measures of inventory inventory was
already constrained at the beginning at
the at the left side of this graph if
you will
now we're seeing a much more constrained
housing inventory and that translates
into costs for people in terms of their
ability to purchase a home and the you
know what they might have for a monthly
mortgage payment or as you can see on
slide 24 how it interacts with the
rental market
this is a much longer time horizon on
this graph we don't have as as
frequented data on the rental side but
uh from 2011 to 2021 you can see on the
bars the vacancy rate has gone down
quite a bit
and uh and the median meant uh monthly
rent uh and utility costs for a two
bedroom apartment has gone up from a
little over a thousand dollars a month
to just under fifteen hundred dollars a
month statewide and that's a quite
significant increase in costs um
particularly given that renters tend to
be lower incomes and have a
considerably lower median household
income based on the available data that
we have
and one more constraint that i want to
point to when it comes to what does if
if the what are the headwinds that the
economy faces in new hampshire that
might lead to um or that might increase
the risk of um either a recession or a
slowdown um one uh is the because the
continued impacts of the virus and also
the limited child care access that we
had before the pandemic
that's likely leading quite a few people
to at least curtail their hours in terms
of their participation in the workforce
and what you see in this pie chart on
slide 25 is the percentage again these
are the census bureau household pulse
survey data this is the percentage of
adults with children under five who said
that in their
in their child care plans um in the last
four weeks and looking at september to
january september of last year to
january of this year um
you know 30 percent or i should say one
in three or more than one in three
adults identifying that is quite
significant in terms of the amount of
impact it can have on people's ability
to engage in the labor force
so the next question um that i want to
address is the question posed in january
2021 will there be sufficient training
or education opportunities to prepare
people to enter a post-pandemic economy
well i'm going to contend a little bit
that we aren't quite yet in a
post-pandemic economy but there is a
significant opportunity
i would say to
at least in terms of formal
upskilling of the workforce in new
hampshire if there is if we get to a
point where
it's clear that the post-pandemic
economy would be better addressed by by
a labor force that has more formal
education or more higher formal
education
so we can see that the
this pie chart on slide 27 shows the
educational attainment in new hampshire
in 2019 and shows the median annual
incomes and we can see that those annual
incomes do go up as the level of formal
educational attainment does increase um
obviously you know this this isn't
necessarily the path for everyone but we
can see that roughly a little bit more
than a quarter of the population age 25
years and older
had a high school degree or equivalent
and then of roughly one in five had some
college but no degree
and uh that that group in particular
means that you might have for example
student debt associated with college but
you don't have the degree to sort of
unlock those higher level of wages so
this is just to give you a picture of
where we were before the pandemic i am
focusing a little bit on adults here
this age uh population 25 years and
older because if you look at the next
slide you can see that the um the number
of children who are likely going to be
entering the workforce in the future has
been declining right this is the this
graph on slide 28 shows the student
enrollment in new hampshire's public
schools and it peaked around
2002 2003
and has been dropping since then you can
see that in the most recent years we've
seen the impacts of the pandemic
particularly on the 2020-2021 school
year although there has been a little
bit of a rebound since then but
this suggests that there are going to be
fewer people entering the workforce from
new hampshire schools than we've seen in
the past and this is again a long-term
demographic trend
and even relative to other states and if
you look on slide 29 even relative to
other states
this is an important consideration when
we think about economic growth going
forward
this graph on slide 29 shows the
percentage change in the number of
children the number of people under age
18 in each state if you compare the 2010
to the 2020 census counts and new
hampshire saw the largest percentage
decline of any state
in the number of children who lived in
the state
so that's significant when it comes to
what do we have to think about in new
hampshire in particular when it comes to
the economy when it comes to the the
workforce
et cetera
now on slide 30 we begin the next
question which is will wages grow
meaningfully and this is an important
question because in the last economic
recovery real wages didn't grow for many
workers particularly workers with median
or lower incomes consistently throughout
that recovery what you can see on slide
31 is a graph that many of you have seen
before
which shows the wages the
inflation-adjusted wages comparing the
2004 to 2006 period so before the
recession
to 2017 to 2019
and you can see that those lower
percentile wage groups didn't really see
significant wage growth relative to
inflation and indeed if you were to take
a snapshot of a few years before saw
wages that were had not kept up with
inflation um the median wage had kept up
with inflation for a good portion of
that time but
was still behind for some of the great
recession and ended the recovery from
the great recession at about where it
was before and you can see that higher
wages did grow relative to inflation
so
we don't have these data unfortunately
yet for the sort of post pandemic
or the post the beginning of the
pandemic but
we do have some data and slide 32 shows
some of this higher frequency data that
does um give us a picture as to
what the impacts were what the
distributional impacts were on
employment based on what jobs the jobs
paid
and this shows that if you look
especially in that first year of the
pandemic there was a very significant
drop
in um in employment across the board but
it was particularly severe for lower
wage work and that lower wage work took
a longer time to recover
now
last year senator gaida had asked about
what portion of the population what
portion of jobs are actually in that
low-wage group in new hampshire
these data are based on
national level quartiles so that low
wage group is the bottom 25 percent the
high wage group is the top 25 percent in
the middle wage group is the middle 50
percent
new hampshire is a little bit of a
higher wage state generally than a lot
of other states around the country so
that low wage group may be a little bit
less than that 25 percent
however
if you look at household incomes prior
to the pandemic
then about one in five households in new
hampshire had less than 35 000 per year
in income again that's households not
jobs so it's not exactly the same unit
of measurement but suggests that it's
pretty close in new hampshire to you
know maybe that bottom quartile
senator hennessey also asked a question
last year around
what may be happening uh within the
economy when there were so many low-wage
positions that she was seeing unfilled
in the economy um and uh and senator i
think what you may have been seeing as
we can see later in this graph is that
we see middle wage and high-wage job
growth that you know at least based on
these data may be outpacing what we saw
what what we see as the overall job
growth in new hampshire and that is the
so the hopeful interpretation of that is
that more people who were previously in
low-wage work have been able to migrate
into what you might categorize as middle
wage work or even higher wage work um in
the towards the end of this graph but
again the data here end in august so
there's still some unanswered questions
but um but that may be part of what
we're seeing
now one uh
one thing that i want to show to remind
uh to remind all of us about is the what
employment looked like before the
pandemic and how it was broken up by
industry you can see that on slide 33
this is again a similar graph to what i
showed you um uh back at the back
at uh in january 2021 um healthcare and
social assistance has had recently
passed retail trade as the largest
employer in the state and then
manufacturing educational services and
accommodation food services rounded out
the top five and together accounted for
more than half the employment in the
state
what happened to wages in those sectors
well we can have some insight now
although the data do lag a little bit
the data on slide 34 show the total and
then those five sectors i'm comparing
weekly wage growth in january to june of
20 or probably weekly wage growth in new
hampshire between
the first half of 2019 and the first
half of 2021
and we see the nominal wage growth so
not adjusted for inflation in the solid
bar and then in the crosstatch bar
inflation-adjusted wage growth
and we can see that
wages have been growing overall although
real wages in particular for
manufacturing have been the growth has
been a little bit more muted um
healthcare and social assistance we see
a little bit more muted growth as well
in those wages um and in all these
sectors it appears to be you know maybe
a little bit lower than what we're
seeing
overall in the economy and combined
across the other sectors but again this
is comparing the first half of last year
to the first half of the year before the
pandemic we don't have these granular
data from more recent data at least i
don't have access to that but if you
look at slide 35 you can see with
slightly different categorizations
broader categorizations of
median wages what's happened to the
median wages in these sectors
first i want to draw your attention on
this graph to the solid the thick solid
line
without any markings on it and that is
the total private sector median wage
this is comparing this is looking month
to month with monthly median wage
estimates in new hampshire and
monthly inflation estimates from the
bureau of labor statistics you can see
that the median wage in december of 2021
is about where it was in january of 2021
relative to inflation so median wage
growth did not outpace inflation even
though there was wage growth over this
year
um however that is a little bit
different for some of the industries so
we can look at trade transportation
utilities that may have outpaced wage
growth we have a question and then oh
yes absolutely representative aaron
thank you mr chair and thank you mr uh
stat slutten for uh your presentation
thus far i my question is i i'm looking
at these graphs and i'm trying to
think of how
it is incorporated into this data
wages that
may have risen because
employers were trying to retain people
uh and and not have them stay home
versus you know
find another job somewhere else
do you see that any of any of the data
suggests that
yeah i think the data the data i think
especially in the last few months of
this past year
pretty broadly suggest to me that
they're that employers are having
trouble finding workers and part of it
is workers may for whatever reason be
opting to keep themselves out of the
labor force whether it's for health
reasons or because they have other
caregiving responsibilities for example
um
employer employees may also be moving um
either negotiating more with their
employers or moving between jobs to seek
those higher to seek higher wages if
there are other opportunities out there
that do offer higher wages i think that
that's part of what we're seeing
i think that the the general lack of
supply in the labor force
and the prospect for continued general
lack of supply in the labor force is
definitely affecting what we're seeing
in terms of wage growth particularly in
these lower wage sectors that again in
the recovery from the great recession
didn't see much wage growth to begin
with if any real wage growth to begin
with so there may be some you know some
correction for that that's happening
here but i have to believe that there's
a very significant sort of short-term
impact from the pandemic that we're
still seeing sort of shake out if you
will in some of these wage figures
particularly for low-wage workers so i
hope that addressed your question yeah
thank you okay you're welcome
so
yes okay thank you so i'll point um
especially in the last few months and
again these are preliminary data to
leisure and hospitality which includes
those accommodation food service workers
um and education health services which
includes the health care and social
assistance workers um that in the last
sort of four or four months that we see
of 2021 we saw more significant wage
growth there again based on these
preliminary data
and that does suggest workforce
shortages particularly i would say in
the health sector as well there's been a
lot of discussion of that
and
the
risk of inflation outpacing the wage
growth that we see
is significant especially for especially
for households that may be on more
limited incomes or on on fixed incomes
or limited growth incomes
you can see here these are data on this
pie chart on slide 36 from the
massachusetts institute of technology's
living wage calculator covering roughly
2020 and 2021 based on their publication
some of these costs that we've already
spoken about or that we discussed in the
that you discussed in the last
presentation food cost for example child
care costs housing costs these are
significant slices of the pie um and as
these increase that puts pressure on on
everything else if you will
in terms of in terms of people's ability
to afford household expenses
now
we asked a question in january of 2021
about future federal action and how does
that support the economy
and how does that support the ability of
individuals and families to to make ends
meet themselves
and i think it's worth it to say in
summary that those policy responses have
been significant and have been very
helpful
if you look at the graph on slide 38
this is again the census bureau's
household pulse survey
this is measuring the per pardon mean
the percentage of adults in new
hampshire that said it was somewhat or
very difficult to pay for usual
household expenses in the last seven
days
and you can see unfortunately we don't
have these data again before the
pandemic or from the earliest part but
if you look on the left side of the
graph you can see in 2020 that number
had risen to roughly one in three adults
saying it was somewhat or very difficult
to pay for those usual household
expenses
which is a significant portion of the
population clearly
then you can see the policy
interventions here
at the federal level the consolidated
appropriations act is what mr white
called the december aid package and
noted that it didn't have a very
eloquent name the consolidated
appropriations act is the name for that
omnibus bill
and you can see that it appeared after
that bill and that bill as a reminder
expanded
food assistance benefits under the
supplement nutrition assistance program
provided the economic impact payments or
commonly known as the stimulus checks um
also expanded unemployment compensation
again as well not to the levels that it
had been in 2020 but higher than the
levels that would have been
you can see that it appeared that that
that hardship measure the somewhat or
very difficult measure in terms of
paying for usual household expenses did
decline we also see a decline after the
american rescue plan act which again
kept those unemployment compensation
expansions sent out the economic impact
payments and had the snap benefit
extension increase
increase and they extended the increase
pardon me
and then the third line that you'll see
on this graph are the american rescue
plan acts child tax credit monthly
payments
and these were these were delayed
relative to the initial passage of the
act but
started in mid-july and lasted through
mid-december and we can see again
there's a reduction in hardship there
now uh the economy was also improving
through this time so there are
definitely other factors but we do see
this pattern that suggests that the
federal economic stimulus had a pretty
significant impact on people's ability
to afford goods
including you know these data are from
new hampshire if we look at national
data
then we can see on slides 39 40 and 41 i
layer in different lines that are
estimates of poverty
so the first slide slide 39 shows
similar policy interventions although
shows also the regular tax credits that
are usually delivered around this time
of year
if you look at the monthly traditional
poverty rate on slide 39 estimated by
researchers at the university of chicago
you can see there's dips in the national
poverty rate after each one of those
policy interventions
layering in
the supplemental poverty rate the
estimated supplemental poverty rate
which is a different the supplemental
poverty measure tries to be a little bit
more comprehensive in terms of measuring
costs
researchers at columbia university
estimated what the impacts or what that
was on a monthly basis and if you look
on slide 41 they show
what the supplemental poverty rate
likely would have been without those
pandemic-related federal policy
interventions and you could see here at
least based on their model estimates
that there's a pretty clear reduction in
the poverty rate rel because of those
pandemic interventions
and it's not necessarily a surprise that
we see
as mr white alluded to that we see these
federal
impacts on
on our economy as
really being effective economic stimulus
not just because of their size but also
because of how they were targeted if you
look at slide 42 you can see
this is these are model these are
numbers that are used in moody's
analytics modeling that were published
in january of 2021 measuring what the
impact would be of an additional dollar
of expenditure or a reduced dollar in
taxes
of economic stimulus in the first
quarter of 2021 relative to the fourth
quarter and we can see that there were
more stimulative impacts associated with
for example uh supplemental nutrition
assistance program benefits or food
stamp expansion
we can see that there were more
stimulative impacts associated with
unemployment compensation increases um
associated with aid to state and local
governments the earned income tax credit
the child tax credit these were all key
components of the american rescue plan
act and
as you can see they're targeted at being
more economically stimulative it's not
necessarily a surprise that we've seen
this economic growth increase as a
result and after
these federal aid packages
now that's the federal government side
what about the state what role will the
state play in supporting the recovery
and what role has it played
well there has been a the state has had
a federally enhanced role and many of
you are involved in this and have been
involved in this
first from the cares act coronavirus
relief funds that was the 1.25 billion
dollars the state received that provided
significant aid that was used by the
state to provide significant aid to
businesses to state services to health
and long-term care providers for child
care for schools for non-profits for
housing these are all touching on these
areas that we've discussed as potential
areas of economic constraint as well as
that immediate relief that we saw
delivered in 2020
there's a much longer time horizon for
the american rescue plan acts fiscal
recovery funds that the state has which
is a slightly smaller amount of just
under a billion dollars you can see in
the pie chart
roughly how those dollars have been
appropriated thus far and again in
relatively broad categories
obviously not each individual
expenditure is represented here and i do
want to note also the investments made
by um by recent state budgets including
in mental health um because mental
health has a strong interaction with the
workforce um you know keeping the mental
health of the population
healthier if you will
and medicaid reimbursement rates that
obviously interacts with the health care
workforce as well
now what happens to the international
economy and trade and there's a lot that
could be said here and we've just had a
longer discussion than i could provide
about that
but i think it is worth thinking about
especially if we're thinking about state
revenues in particular
because the the unanswered questions
that we have could
substantially impact state revenues in
new hampshire um whether it's a new
variance of covert 19 or some new
iteration of the virus
and how that impacts
other countries that have had different
policies particularly china relative to
handling the pandemic that could be a
significant factor going forward
supply chain bottlenecks fossil fuel
costs obviously there's some
geopolitical considerations with what is
happening in eastern europe right now
and the reason i mention all these
things is because if you look at new
hampshire's largest state tax revenue
source the business profits tax which is
the largest tax revenue source by a
factor of two in the most
in the most recent fiscal year um
that is uh heavily dependent on
business entities that are filing as
water's edge entities so these are
entities that have a significant
overseas component and are also
operating in new hampshire
they paid about 60 percent of the
business profits tax that was paid in
tax year 2019
so which are the most recent data that
we have from revenue department revenue
administration so
what happens internationally
could definitely have an impact on new
hampshire's state revenue picture
and then what happens to commercial
property values what happens to tourism
what happens in other areas of the
economy
i would say that again this is an
evolving picture particularly relative
to commercial property and it's not
something i watch closely enough to be
able to say definitively what trend is
happening residential property has
clearly
gone up in value
i'll note as you can see on the graph
that this is very important for local
revenue and local public services
the property tax is the local property
taxes by far the largest source of state
of state and local revenue combined
in terms of tax revenue um and i will
say one thing about tourism too
is that tourism and we and you heard
some discussion last month
about how robust the last tourist season
particularly last summer has been and i
think that may persist especially with
remote work enabling more maybe shorter
trips to new hampshire people may be
able to work on a friday or monday
adjacent to a shorter trip
and people may be able to live locally
more than they would have otherwise but
i do wonder one of the key questions i
have is what happens to regional tourism
we get a lot of tourists in new
hampshire obviously from the boston
metropolitan area from the new york
metropolitan area from states like
connecticut new jersey massachusetts
clearly
if we get to a point this summer where
more people are more comfortable
traveling further say to colorado or
france for example what does that do to
tourism in new hampshire is that a net
positive impact because we attract more
people from colorado and france or is it
uh is it more of a downward impact
relative to what we saw in 2021 when
people wanted to stay a little bit more
locally so that's a consideration i have
as well
so part three and i promised part three
would be shorter
part 3 are some considerations just
specific to revenue that didn't fit into
any part of this presentation earlier
one is on as you can see on page 50
which shows
the
total sales volume in dollars for
single-family homes and condos and then
of course delayed by one month the real
estate transfer tax revenues collected
how long does the housing supply last
and what does that mean for revenues
going forward this is a question that
we've been asking for years and we've
seen the housing supply constraints
become more and more acute so what that
does to revenues going forward
specifically the real estate transfer
taxes i think a key question
then on the next slide property taxes
the property tax growth has historically
outpaced inflation
that may not be the case going forward
if we have higher inflation you can see
on this graph which shows 2009 to 2021
the aggregate local property tax
commitment in 2021 the number went down
um and that's likely federal aid played
a role in that but also some of the
state budget decisions around more state
aid to local governments likely played a
role in that as well i don't have a
comprehensive set of factors for you but
that's that's what i see when i look at
this but
if property taxes do outpace inflation
uh and inflation is squeezing other
parts of household budgets what are the
property tax implica or what are the
implications there for people's ability
to pay property taxes and how does that
affect the economy too
and then on page 52 on slide 52 you'll
see u.s corporate profits and i do want
to note that corporate profits at in the
u.s level have gone up quite a bit even
in the last few quarters so this is only
through quarter 3 of 2021
but we've seen really significant growth
on the national level
and how does that persist how do does
that continue does that fall and
if you and that's important for new
hampshire's revenue structure because
again talking about the business profits
tax if you look at slide 53 we have yes
so
what do you suspect is the biggest
reason for the large increase in the
profits tax
in profits tax revenue or in profits tax
revenue yes um so i i think that what
we've seen in business profits tax
revenue is really driven by that slide
that i just showed around u.s corporate
profits and
whether that is because there are um i i
don't know enough about the factors at
the national level to be able to say
definitively what one factor is over
another but i do think that those
national level corporate profit trends
are what's driving our business profits
tax revenue i hope i'm addressing your
question yes
i'm more interested in the relationship
between
the federal stimuluses
and the
increase in the province tax
yeah so i think that the federal
stimulus is definitely because of the
increased business activity and because
of the business the shifts in business
activity that we've seen as well so that
services to goods shift for example um
to the extent that that
has that both the federal stimulus going
to households and the savings that
especially higher income households that
haven't seen their incomes interrupted
have accrued um
that
i think that that has likely led to some
businesses and we've heard this from the
department of revenue administration
some businesses doing very well in terms
of their profits relative to what
they've had before because suddenly
there's more demand for their goods so
there may be businesses that are more
service focused that saw lower corporate
profits but we saw higher corporate
profits especially from businesses where
there was suddenly more demand for their
goods and they could in some cases
charge higher prices as a result um so
chairman major i hope that addressed
your question
we'll talk later okay that sounds great
thank you and i'm also happy to take
questions during the during the lunch
hour i will i will stick around
um
so um slide 53 is just really a
derivation of what um especially the
folks on the ways and means committees
are used to seeing with the inverted
triangle and department of revenue
administration reports um
one thing to emphasize there again when
we're talking about u.s corporate
profits uh
being an important factor the top one
tenth of one percent of businesses in
terms of the amount of taxable profits
that they had paid close to 44 of the
business profits tax revenue collected
in tax year 2019
and the top uh 110 uh pardon the top
less than one percent paid close to or
more than three quarters so put another
way you can see on slide 54
the top 80 filers paid about 226 million
dollars of business profits tax revenue
in 2019 and if you add another roughly
600 again important key businesses in
the state are paying three quarters of
the business profits tax there so that
what happens at the national level with
national corporate profits and how they
persist is i think really important for
the revenue forecast
so
and speaking of that revenue forecast on
slide 55 i put together a short list of
considerations which i'll run through
quickly here um
i think the forecast is complicated
in part because we've seen so much
revenue growth in recent years
that understanding the baseline is i
think i think
somewhat difficult
in fiscal year 2021 revenues were up 13
from fiscal year 2019 and up 32 from
2015.
that's really significant growth
that growth especially the recent growth
that we've seen
i think is likely to slow as the as
economic growth slows and we heard again
earlier this morning about some of the
economic headwinds um whether
there are declines outside of the tax
rate reductions that we're that we're
seeing in current policy
outside of those if you're to set those
aside whether revenues decline i don't
know or if they just slow down i think
that's a key question
the business tax rate reductions and the
changes in the business tax bases may
make it difficult to evaluate some of
those individual policy impacts um the
reduction in the meals and rentals tax
rate will reduce revenue relative to
what it was what it would have been um
the interest and dividends tax phase out
will reduce revenue relative to what it
would have been
so that will start to decline over time
stock market volatility is obviously
also a factor there
and
for members of the finance committee i
did note that the medicaid enhancement
tax revenue increases
will likely offset some of the general
fund expenditures on medicaid overall
and i think that's that's an important
part of the picture but i don't exactly
know where that's going to go going
forward
so i have some questions for the economy
in 2022
does it continue to grow robustly and
equitably
or does is growth less inclusive or does
it slow or stall
and do incomes for households workers
and businesses outpace inflation and
rising prices i think that's a key
question
what happens to the size of the
workforce and why does the size of the
workforce change what are the factors
that contribute to that
how are critical workforce challenges in
key sectors particularly direct health
services and child care services how are
they addressed going forward
does the housing shortage ease
i think is again a really key question
for not just the people currently in new
hampshire but attracting more people to
new hampshire
are there more dangerous sarsko v2
variants and if there aren't which
hopefully there won't be
what happened what are the changes that
we've seen in the economy that are
permanent that remain going forward
and then how does the state deploy
resources including federal funds to
support individuals families and the
economy
and with that um i'll take us back to
our key takeaways which we discussed at
the beginning so i'll uh shorten it here
just to say that you know we've seen um
we've seen federal assistance really
help economic growth but the recovery is
not complete we're not back at trendline
and the recovery has been uneven
as we've seen in some of these graphs
the workforce constraints are a really
significant headwind and then health
factors and child care factors are
severe limitations as well as some of
those long-term trends
inflation is you know hopefully a quite
a temporary phenomenon but um it's it
has definitely impacted household
budgets in 2021 and the state has some
really significant opportunities
especially with flexible available
federal resources to help build an
equitable and inclusive recovery going
forward in the state so thank you very
much for your time i know i'm running
right up against time so again i'm happy
to stick around afterwards and answer
questions as well unless you want me to
take some now
thank you phil for uh excellent
presentation
right we have one minute we have one
minute
so uh representative ellen
thank you uh phil
on
we are coming up next year on the single
sales factor
change
we are
taking an incredible wager on what's
going to happen when we exclude
capital uh
and
and wages from the equation
almost all of our money is coming from
the richest corporations and the the
corporations
that are multi-state
multi-nation
on
we can't get information from dra
to deal with this they can't produce it
at least not until
a year that we already will have been
experiencing this problem do you have
any thoughts or could you develop any
thoughts on
what kind of information we could get at
the national level that would allow us
to
to estimate in some way what's going to
happen to our business profit stacks
yeah so representative family that's a
great question and i think the
especially given the time constraints
the answer that i'll give now is i'm
happy to work on developing thoughts and
i can get back to you um and to the
committees on that front
you're welcome thank you phil and that's
it for time
right on time right good
thank you very much i appreciate the
opportunity thank you
are we all set jennifer
okay good
well jennifer's distributing the
handouts
i'll introduce the
michael skelton from
and david you are
okay
and
you're michael skelton
okay
michael skelton currently serves as
president
and ceo of the business and industry
association of new hampshire
the state's leading business advocate
and statewide chamber of commerce
previously michael served as president
and ceo of the greater manchester
chamber
the state's largest regional chamber of
commerce
in total michael has more than 12 years
of leadership experience in the chamber
of commerce industry and brings a
background in public relations
media relations economic development and
government affairs to his roles
michael is a member of the board of
directors of amish industry
a member of the board of trustees of
manchester
palace theater and was appointed by
governor sununu to serve as a board
member of the new hampshire housing
finance authority
joining michael today will be val
zanczyk president of graph
graphic cast in jaffrey
representing the manufacturing sector
neil proudman president
of liberty in londonderry representing
the utility sector
jeff mciver president
general manager of the mountain club on
loan
in lincoln
representing the travel and tourism
sector
and
michael waters in the department
from dartmouth hitchcock health in
hanover representing the healthcare
sector so michael
you and your crew
have it all right now
thank you representative uh appreciate
the opportunity to be here today an
invitation to uh to speak with you all
um
i am as you as you mentioned uh mike
skelton president ceo of the business
industry association of new hampshire
relatively new to my role
for about a month
but
have a long history in the
chamber industry here in new hampshire
so very familiar with our state's
business community a little background
on the on the bia just before we get
started and i hand it over to our
business leaders who have joined us
today is
as you mentioned the bia serves as our
statewide chamber of commerce
manufacturing association and the
state's leading business advocate
we represent more than 400 members in a
variety of industries including advanced
manufacturing high technology
professional services financial services
health care hospitality and tourism
public utilities higher education
insurance
our members employ nearly 90 000 people
throughout the state of new hampshire
which represents one in seven new
hampshire jobs and contributes 4.5
billion annually to our our state's
economy
and again i want to thank you for the
opportunity to share some insights on
the current challenges facing our
business community and an outlook for
uh the year ahead and
has has been our tradition with this
opportunity
really the best way
we think to provide you with those
insights is for you to hear them
directly from
business leaders themselves
so
um as you uh indicated introduced we've
uh
invited four of our uh leading business
members to join us today representing
different sectors i'm going to introduce
each of them very briefly and have them
come up and give about five minutes of
comments
and then after they all speak we would
be more than happy to answer questions
and um or respond to any comments or
ideas that that you have
and i did want to mention also that joe
murray from
fidelity
representing the financial services
sector was not able to join us today
but uh sent along some written uh
comments that uh are available for your
your review
so i'm gonna start with val zanchuk
representing the manufacturing sector uh
val is the president owner of graphicast
a manufacturing company located in
jaffrey he's a past chair of the bia and
serves on the boards of the sea science
center new hampshire learning initiative
new hampshire manufacturing extension
partnership in the manufacturing
leadership council
val is a graduate of lehigh university
and holds a bachelor's and master's
degree in metallurgical engineering so
i'm going to hand it over to val
one i think val has
serves on the pre-engineering technology
advisory council
which i serve
we serve many years together
representative major thank you and good
morning everyone
manufacturing is in an interesting
position right now if we go back two
years to the beginning of the the
pandemic most of us were working our way
out of a long manufacturing recession
that began globally around 2015 or 16
and just as the uh the pandemic was
coming in
um we at least in our company we were
seeing the best year we had in about
four years
and then that was cut short
when uh covet came so we had a an
initial
positive response to covid because many
of our customers are in the medical
equipment business so we saw a lot of
activity with them but by
august of 2020 we had our worst
new orders booking month in company
history we booked one order for about
twenty five hundred dollars and this is
for a company that could be shipping
anywhere from 250 to 300 000 a month of
product so to have an almost zero month
was unheard of the interesting thing is
nine months later we had almost a record
high number of orders
so this as i mentioned this is uh the
dickens uh
manufacturing
sector you know it was the best of times
and the worst of times because it all
happened so quickly and a lot of
companies went through very similar
circumstances that we did we didn't all
have
the response at the same rate at the
same time so some peaked early some
peaks later
um i i know some companies that
were
not doing well six months ago when we
were seeing a 60 increase in our new
bookings and now that company is is
seeing records as well so we're uh
in this very strange situation where
the whole pandemic
probably ended up being a net positive
thing for most manufacturers because
the demand right now is so high with
with everything in the economy shutting
down for for a good portion of the last
two years and still with many sectors of
the economy not back up to 100 percent
uh we're seeing those who are recovering
now ordering at
incredibly uh you know long and deep uh
levels uh as i mentioned in my comments
here we're booking production now for
january of 2023. that's how many orders
we have we cannot keep up with it
we are capacity constrained um not as
much for equipment as we are for people
we simply cannot find people we never
laid off people we operated during
the entire pandemic as most
manufacturers did so we were there
through the whole thing keeping our
operations going but but right now
there are a lot of demands out there for
manufacturing people cnc machine
operators and others and
we we put ads out and we get no response
um
you know or if we do get a response and
we
you know we we reach out to the people
we want to see them they ghost us we
never hear back from them and this has
been happening now for the past six or
eight months so i think you're going to
see a lot of manufacturers in a position
similar to ours demand is extremely high
the labor force is low
we we can't
we can't meet the demand i mean we're
late on everything we're stretching our
our lead times out to 26 weeks
which is not an enjoyable number to have
but
we've had to prioritize all of our
customers because we just can't keep up
with everything and i know a lot of
companies are in the same same boat on
the other hand there's an other shortage
which is on the material side and the
supply chain issue
we're lucky in that we buy a global
commodity and the price is going up
rapidly right now especially with the
with the war in europe
but we have it available there are many
other customers who just can't find raw
materials so they could make the stuff
that they could find the material to to
use but they
just can't do it and as i mentioned some
are suffering from material shortages
some are suffering for labor shortages
and some are suffering for both
and what happens is many of us are in
the supply chain of larger companies so
as our lead times go up their lead times
go up so we just make that whole supply
chain issue even worse
a lot of companies are trying to
overcome the the problem of labor with
greater automation
you know trying to
automate as much as they can to replace
labor if possible and then using newer
techniques like i mentioned data
analytics artificial intelligence all of
these sort sorts of things are coming
into play now where we can understand
our businesses better try to cut our
costs try to be more sustainable in our
operations everything that we can do to
sustain ourselves uh you know through
this through this change the national
association of manufacturers indicates
that
their expectation is the economy will
continue to grow in 2022 for about four
percent growth which is still pretty
pretty aggressive um so we don't see the
supply chain issue
dissipating for some time it's going to
be tough and
i see no end in sight for for our
business in terms of orders
exceeding shipments so every month my
backlog just keeps growing and we work
overtime we you know we're trying to
find people uh we just can't keep up
with it so we we get increasingly behind
in trying to do things and i think
everyone is in that in that position
right now so uh manufacturing is still a
strong sector in the in the state
employing about 70 000 people we'd like
to employ more if we can um i think
you'll see manufacturing companies doing
as well as they can with all of the the
constraints that they have um and i
think you know it'll be
you know a few years before we can find
ourselves in a in a more easy breathing
situation than we are right now
thank you
so next i'm going to introduce neil
proudman to
speak on behalf of the utilities and
energy sector
neil is the president of liberty new
hampshire stepping into that role
in march of last year
neil's utility career began when he
joined british gas in 1979 specializing
in natural gas distribution and
transmission operations
after which he rose to become the head
of gas operations for wales and the west
of england in 2003 neil came to the us
on assignment for national grid he's
remained here ever since becoming a u.s
citizen in 2017.
neil's career in the u.s has featured
leadership experience in electrical
construction and maintenance operational
support services utility acquisitions
and gas operations while leading
national grids new england gas business
and neil is also a newer member of the
bias board of directors and we're very
pleased to have him in that role so neil
take it away
okay
so so good morning and
thank you to the members of the
committees for the opportunity to speak
today
i am neil proudman i'm the president of
liberty new hampshire we we serve around
46 000 electric customers and
around 96 000 gas customers across the
territory
this is my second year i'm just starting
my second year in the job and it's also
my second year as a granite stater um i
i did come across uh to the u.s in 2003
with my family on a two-year assignment
and i stayed and uh and and i became a
proud american
in 2017 on on the 4th of july that that
never gets old
it never gets old
um the energy sector plays an essential
role in new hampshire's economy the
electricity and gas delivered by liberty
and new hampshire's other utilities is
absolutely fundamental to all the
economic activity in the state we do
everything from heating homes to
powering industry
access to safe affordable and reliable
energy is a necessary prerequisite for
new hampshire's economic success
for me the central challenge facing new
hampshire's energy economy
is that the supply and price of our
energy
is not determined here in new hampshire
it is determined by forces beyond our
borders
and in a large part beyond our control
which is very frustrating to me
by virtue of new hampshire's geographic
location we're on the end of a very very
long pipeline
and and that creates a bottleneck and it
drives up prices and and the price that
customers pay for heating and fuel
and electricity which is generated
primarily by gas-burning power plants is
some of the highest in the country and
let me give you a quick example i'm
going off script now a quick example on
the 28th of january there was a trading
situation on the last day on the last
day of trading
at the uh henry hub in louisiana last
time i checked that's a long way from
new hampshire
reuters and the market analysts didn't
know what was happening but there was a
spike in trading at the very last minute
the impact of that spike in trading
is
a month
on on on the energy bill of the average
residential
new hampshire family
now some people would say 16 isn't a lot
but but that's not my background and
that's not where i come from
and i know that when i when i when i
when i stand in that line at my local
market basket with those new hampshire
families
a new hampshire mom can do a lot with 16
bucks
you know i see a lot of great examples
in the last year of of what live free
and dime means to granite staters and
this doesn't feel like it
historically as i've said new hampshire
tends to have some of the highest energy
costs in the country
so what can we and state polit
policymakers do to reduce this kind of
volatility and price risk
well firstly we can help energy
consumers
to lower their energy costs through
energy efficiency and i'm really pleased
that the governor signed house bill 549
which established a new robust
foundation for cost-effective energy
efficiency programmes under the
award-winning new hampshire saves it's a
time when energy prices are most
volatile we have an opportunity to help
our customers the cheapest energy is the
energy you don't use
we really appreciate the governor the
legislature the department of energy and
the office of the consumer advocate our
fellow utilities and others for coming
together to help granite staters save
money
second we can produce and store our own
energy right here in new hampshire for
example we can optimize the integration
of distribution energy resources so they
add value for all utility customers a
good example of this is liberty's own
battery storage pilot program it's a
prime example of where third policy
developers utilities and customers can
work together to reduce costs and
enhance electric system resiliency by
integrating behind the meter resources
if implanted correctly community power
aggregation aided by reliable access to
utility energy data can also help
and we can do more to insulate new
hampshire families and businesses from
the high prices and volatility of the
institut in interstate gas transmission
system by using
local waste streams renewable energy to
generate renewable natural gas and clean
energy clean hydrogen that can be
delivered to customers through our
existing
infrastructure that the ratepayers of
new hampshire have paid for over decades
we can improve new hampshire's capacity
for long
duration storage
so my third and final point is that we
should modernize the process utilities
use to plan for the future
the existing state statute governing
least cost integrated resource planning
is really a vestige of the
vertically integrated utility days and
does little
to optimize utility holistic utility
system planning to meet the needs of our
communities
with the right policy the right
collaboration and regulatory framework
in place new hampshire new hampshire's
energy system can make progress towards
a more affordable and resilient future
what i'm really saying there
is that if we come together as a
community like we do
and like we did for energy efficiency
the legislature the department of energy
consumer advocates
and utilities
we combine our talents
our energies and through the efficient
use
of our customer funding
we can provide ourselves with a buffer
from that volatility
through a measure of energy independence
using our own
new hampshire waste for for renewable
natural gas using our own new hampshire
water to produce hydrogen using our own
new hampshire wind and sunshine and the
geothermal heat
underneath our feet
before i close i would be remiss if i
didn't call your attention to a key
a key issue facing new hampshire
businesses including utilities
and that's the workforce the existing
utility workforce is aging
i've been in this industry for four
years i i feel it believe me
what we need is smart hard-working young
granite staters who want to stay here
and join our workforce
and then coupled with that a strategy to
attract the best and brightest work
workers from
from from all over to give our essential
industries like the utilities the brain
power to move forward and continue to
serve our customers
we need truck drivers we need trades
people we need engineers
like all businesses we've been dealing
with covid and
and and these have been very challenging
times but i have to pay tribute to our
own workforce for their diligence their
safety and their continuing commitment
to serve our customers through this
pandemic
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak today this is my first
opportunity to speak in new hampshire
and i'm happy to answer any questions uh
that's good representative weiler has a
question
thank you mr chairman thank you sir have
a constituent that always keep telling
me we're missing the
missing the chance of molten salt
reactors have you looked at that at all
i i i haven't i'm afraid
but i can i can certainly do that and
come back to you
okay and we'll save the rest of the
questions uh okay one more question and
then we'll go to the next speaker
representative
thanks i'm from lebanon so i appreciate
very much what you've been doing
on i just wanted to
find out if all of the utilities are
pretty much on board with these ideas
i can only speak for liberty right now
we do collaborate we certainly
collaborate across across the utility
industry on energy on energy efficiency
and other things but i think we can do
more
so so you're the first audience to hear
this message
and i'm looking forward to not only
working across
the utility but but also
as as i said earlier with the
the office of the consumer advocate the
legislature and the policy makers
i think there's a huge opportunity i
think it's the low hanging fruit and i
think it's the special source that can
help us move forward
and thank you for being one of our
customers in lebanon
all right now we'll listen to the other
two speakers and then have our questions
thank you neil
up next i'd like to introduce jeff
mciver representing the hospitality and
tourism sector
jeff is the
president and gm of the mountain club on
loon mountain club is a 234 room resort
hotel located at the base of loon
mountain
it employs a team of 75 to 100
employees with restaurants and a spa
since 2012 the club has grown from a
three million dollar operation to a 13
million operation here in 2022. jeff
grew up in the hotel and ski industry in
maine he's operated resorts throughout
the west including in alaska he's been
at loon for the past 15 years and he
also spent five years as the managing
partner of the balsams grand resort at
dixville notch so jeff take it away
thank you it's an honor to be here today
especially representing the hospitality
industry of the state of new hampshire
we are in the business of manufacturing
hospitality 24 hours a day
and one of our biggest challenges is
you've heard it previously is this labor
force
our culinary indus our culinarians have
been
very hard to find at the balsams we used
to have a culinary
program there where where we graduated
about six or seven professional chefs
every year and since the balsams is
closed that that has evaporated those
that talent has evaporated
and
it's very very difficult uh to find
staff but
um thank you representatives
for your leadership
when this
terrible pandemic
hit us
without you
not sure what would have happened but
through it all in your courage and
leadership new hampshire
in my opinion has come out ahead from
our neighboring neighbors from our
neighbors in new england
they kept their
they didn't open as soon as we did
they kept their restrictions in place
longer
i also sit on a board of directors for
all the new england inns and resorts in
new england
and weekly calls over the last couple
years i was
amazed
that
colleagues in the industry were remain
closed
while we at loon mountain were
generating cash
and that in the long run i think has
given us a market marketing advantage in
the in the tourism industry for for our
great state
the
restaurant industry received a lot of
support as well as lodging without the
support from the federal government and
from the state of new hampshire
i don't think we would have made it
but we seem to be on the other side of
this pandemic
the restaurant industry is still
i believe going to struggle as
the cases rise and drop
we're hoping our municipalities will
allow us to keep outdoor seating
uh available for at least the next
couple years i think you and your
positions you're going to see
swings in the
laundry and meals tax
swing more in the off seasons than you
maybe did before especially late summer
early winter because i believe the cases
will will rise again and when that
happens it has an impact on our business
[Music]
the
the covet thing is not we believe is not
going to go away
and it's fascinating and it's very good
news that we're being told now we're
going to probably live with it and
manage it which is all good news
for our industry because
without those guests coming from
massachusetts and new hampshire
some of your finest resorts in america
will be struggling and we employ a lot
of people
most of your industries that you're
going to hear from today a lot of those
people that are leaders in those
industries started in our industry let
it be a high school student or college
student
and that's where we have to find our
next workforce and
the biggest challenge will be finding
that workforce and
new hampshire has always led very
strongly in our in hospitality
and it's and we continue to do that
let's see um
it's my pleasure to be here today
in the future you're probably going to
see more
of our restaurants go to a product grab
and go
where you order and you come in and you
pick up your product
and maybe less dining inside
when you go to a hotel you might be
greeted with a kiosk where you check in
without a person to welcome you
and
and that is largely due to technology as
well as the shortage of labor
it goes against my grain i grew up in
this industry
and i love new hampshire because
believe it or not new hampshire
hospitality is real hospitality it's
real people delivering this day in and
day out and we all believe in it and
that is really how we've grown our
revenues at the mountain club on loon
it's you have to develop the product you
have to create a team of hospitality
people that that have smiles
and your clientele will come back year
after year
and as as we go through this shortage of
labor
some of those smiles might diminish and
we have a tremendous amount of people
working six and seven days a week
and
in order to keep the places open but i
know we're not going to fix that today
and
our futures will depend on our
reputation so it is my pleasure and
honor to be here today and and thank you
the folks at bia for inviting me
and their leadership and i encourage you
to always listen to these folks at the
va they're they're our voices
to you and your leadership in the state
of new hampshire
so thank you very much i really
appreciate it
we know the leadership bia very well
okay to wrap up i'd like to introduce
michael waters for representing the
health care sector
mike waters serves as the treasurer for
dartmouth-hitchcock health where he's
worked for 12 years
as treasurer mike's primary
responsibilities are the oversight of
dartmouth hitchcock's invested assets
long-term debt portfolio
and cash management functions
he's spent his whole career in treasury
function including seven years at cns
wholesale grocers in keene new hampshire
mike and his wife cynthia have lived in
chesterfield for 20 years along with
their daughters and mike has an mba from
plymouth state university is a trustee
at cheshire medical center in keene so
mike take it away thank you
good morning everyone
it's a pleasure to be here and it's an
honor to be here thank you thank you
very much
um
i'm here to speak about the challenges
that we are facing here at dartmouth
hitchcock health and they're largely
going to echo
what you've already heard
the challenges that we are facing at
dartmouth hitchcock
they're on several fronts but most
notably around staffing issues expense
growth from salaries and supplies and
affordable housing for our staff
these issues are of course intertwined
with each other but staffing issues
especially for nurses and other clinical
providers directly impacts our ability
to provide care at full capacity
the need for the services we provide at
all of our member hospitals has never
been greater
this is especially true at
dartmouth-hitchcock medical center in
lebanon
the state's only academic medical center
level one trauma center where often
demand for our services outpaces our
ability to provide it even under normal
circumstances
however these are not normal times as
you surely know
as you surely know after two years of
the pandemic clinical providers are
feeling burnout and fatigue
many have retired or left their
healthcare career
in the nursing space this is
exacerbating a pre-covet 19 shortage
that was already making it difficult to
recruit new nurses
across dhh we are taking steps to
recruit and retain workers especially
clinical workers including taking steps
such as increasing pay and offering
signing bonuses
hospitals around the country are doing
the same so the competition for workers
is very intense
our efforts to recruit workers from out
of the area has been complicated by a
severe lack of affordable housing
options especially in lebanon but also
in keene home to chester medical center
in grafton new hampshire recent data
shows that one bedroom apartments have
rents of 1800
per month and two bedroom units are
twenty two hundred dollars per month
using conservative metrics
these rents are five to six hundred
dollars per month above what would be
considered affordable
at dh we've had several instances where
new workers
from out of the area have accepted a job
only to rescind the acceptance later
when they come to the air to secure
housing and can't find it
we also know that many of our staff
drive long distances to work because of
the affordable housing shortage
at dh we are taking on these challenges
head on as best we can thinking boldly
and creatively but they are causing
significant pressures on our expenses
i mentioned earlier the high demand for
services at dhmc
to meet that demand we are in the
process of building a new patient
pavilion
that will add 64 desperately needed beds
and opened in about a year
to finance this project we borrowed 125
million dollars and will incur almost
nine million dollars a year of
additional interest expense as a result
we will of course have to staff these
new beds with even more already hard to
find clinical workers
to track these workers we have increased
salaries to new applicants
which has led us to increase salaries to
existing staff
like most hospitals dhh turns to
traveling nurses to fill
uh staffing gaps when we can't find
enough nurses but this resource has also
been severely disrupted in this
environment the supply of available
traveling nurses has been more limited
during covid
especially during the recent spike
while that access has improved somewhat
the cost of a traveling nurse is very
high so far this fiscal year dhmc's
traveler expense has increased by 40
percent over last year due to both the
increased use of travelers and the
increased cost per traveler
on the housing front we are actively
helping workers secure secure housing a
time-consuming and expensive process
we are also trying to think creatively
as to how we can help encourage and
facilitate the construction of new
affordable housing units in our area
working collaboratively with other
employers in the region
we have also invested 3 million dollars
in the new hampshire community loan fund
these efforts are vital but they are
costly whether it be from increased
salary expense increased recruitment
expense increased interest expense
increase traveler expense
and other increased operating expenses
our total expenses are up almost nine
percent from a year ago
but it does not even begin to fully
capture the increases in our expenses as
they are still bleeding into our into
our operations
at dhh we simply don't have the ability
to pass these expenses on like some
industries do we absorb all of those
expenses
ourselves
so our leadership team continues to
innovate
seek efficiency and think boldly
being fully staffed with a staff of
highly capable highly engaged people is
mission critical for us
and we are determined to succeed but it
is very challenging at the moment we are
doing everything we can to make people
want to come work at dhh we are doing
everything we can to make people want to
come live in new hampshire
we're doing everything we can to take
care of our patients to take care of our
community
thank you for inviting me here today
so thank you mr chairman that concludes
uh our speakers we're happy to use the
rest of our time to respond uh to
questions or or comments
fine the first is from uh representative
browning i got questions for you but
i'll do one and a lot of us ask
questions and we'll see if we can we can
do mike can we start with you so i i
maybe i read this wrong but i thought
somewhere along the line that dartmouth
hitchcock was looking at
kind of getting in the landlord business
and developing some affordable
apartments for staff is did i did i hear
that wrong
is that something you dabbled with uh it
just
it's not a panacea because i i
understand
but did i hear that right or so we did
put out we did put out an rfp a few
months ago uh to
possibly partner with a builder who
would use some land that we were willing
to lease to them but you give them okay
um
uh what we decided was that was going to
actually end up being it wasn't going to
work really we weren't going to be able
to get affordable
uh units unless we put in a substantial
equity uh commitment ourselves which
we're not quite ready to do so we're
we're still trying to think of
short-term solutions that will help
help bring people in now while we assess
whether this is going to be a long-term
problem or not so that's on hold right
now that project okay
thank you that clarifies that appreciate
appreciate that uh
representing elmi
thank you this is kind of a local issue
but i think it may be going on all over
i'm from lebanon uh
every time
dartmouth
tries to expand its student body without
expanding uh housing in the dartmouth
area
and we end up losing a lot of our
workforce in lebanon
we are filled with startups
and when you were going to build that
400 unit
building which we all we permitted uh
very quickly i think uh
to
to house the people that are in that new
74 bed unit
on
that
would have worked but now there is going
to be
nowhere near enough housing for the
people that are running all of these
high-tech creative startups in little
places all over lebanon
and the existing larger
uh
manufacturing
that we have in lebanon and the hospital
and dartmouth college overflow which is
also
being a problem
you have a question on that too
the question is what can we possibly
do i think this is probably a problem
all over the state what can we possibly
do
to
avoid
damaging our existing economy as we grow
in different
try to grow in different parts of it
that are larger like dartmouth hitchcock
is and can
just say well we've got to do something
yeah thank you and that's thank you for
the question um from you know my
perspective this issue hasn't gone away
for us when i say we're not moving on
with that project it's not because the
problem went away
it's still
it's still a big problem we are we are
working with the developers in the area
we are working with other developers
outside the area that might come in with
a different approach maybe more of a
non-profit approach that could help get
more
units built so we're not
we're not by any means walking away from
the situation because we can't
we we need to be able to have people
come in
um
i'm not a policy person so i'll just say
i don't know what the answer is but if
you guys have answers to help us get uh
affordable housing bill
that would help
okay representative ames followed by
senator
roosevelt
thank you i actually have two questions
but i'll put off the second as
representative abrami did
until it's my turn again uh so uh
valzan santrok
a uh
a business operating in my town of
jeffrey um
side by side almost side by side with
millipore
so relatively small manufacturer
and a very big manufacturer expanding
my question to you i don't know
how the business enterprise tax and
business profits tax
interact with you in particular
but as you know
we are moving to a single sales factor
for the business profits tax
and i know that as we've tried to figure
out the impact of this
which is very difficult to do
we see
large manufacturers at least as
primarily selling out
from new hampshire to other places
and we're fearful that going to a single
sales factor
will at least in those cases
hurt our revenues
and i don't know whether that
translates as as well to a smaller
manufacturer it really depends on what
your market is but i wonder if you could
speak to
this issue that we're struggling with
well as a small company relatively small
company
interestingly
business profits tax business enterprise
tax are not a big part of my concern uh
local property taxes far exceed
those other taxes and uh you know being
small company we have a marginal profit
so you know the impact of those taxes to
us is
it's not something that you know we
really take into a lot of consideration
we take advantage of the r d tax credit
which we can do and use that to help
mitigate the tax but it's
compared to
local property taxes
those those taxes really don't affect us
that much and i don't i don't make any
business decisions
you know driven by taxes
um i'm looking more at what makes sense
for our business and where we need to
make investments and whatever and you
know the taxes come as they come but
they're not that large for us so it's
not a major concern
thank you
senator rosenwald
thank you mr chair
my question is from mr waters
thank you
so
we've been hearing a lot from the
hospitals across the state and i'm from
nashua so we've got two and they're not
critical access
that
their
their operating revenues are
struggling
because they've had to cut back
on elective
procedures
for a couple of reasons so
i've noticed at the same time though the
estimated met revenues are up pretty
significantly
from plan so i wonder if you could just
help me understand why
the hospitals are
struggling on revenues and yet
their net
patient service revenues that are taxed
are up
i may have to get back to you on that
i'm not close to the just in my role the
close to how the med is calculated so i
think i'd be speaking out of turn if i
tried to answer that
but i can
come back
roxanna mooney
thank you mr chairman and thank you
gentlemen for being here today
interested to know of the qualified
employees you do hire and that you do
employ
do you have just an informal breakdown
of how many are from out of state and
how many from new hampshire would that
be possible to
formulate a answer on that informally
i can give a quick overview at least in
jeffrey offering
manufacturing jobs um you know we're
paying
entry level workers about 17 an hour
um
and if you look at 17 an hour
to maybe 21 or 22
you know you look at the economic
distance that that wage supports and
maybe you can get a 40-minute commute in
there before you start seeing you know
the cost of commuting
competing with what the with what the
hourly wages so in our case just about
everybody is within 40 minutes of where
we are we may get a couple of people
coming over the border from
massachusetts just because we're so
close
but for us
we recruit locally
we have some people who walk to work
which is a nice situation
we have a pretty good contingent from
the keene area so they have about a half
hour drive but
anything more than a 40-minute commute
doesn't make sense and for the type of
job that we have where the people are
making with overtime and whatever 40 45
000 a year
you know we're not recruiting from out
of state for to try to fill those jobs
so we have to try to look to the local
community to supply
our workforce
just quickly for liberty i would say the
vast majority of our employees all work
all live in in new hampshire we like to
think of ourselves as the fourth
emergency service so when
you know when the weather comes in and
the wires
the wires are crackling on the floor we
need to respond quickly the same
kind of situation when we have a gas
leak so all of our folks need to be
close to be able to respond in a timely
way and uh
and make sure out that our system is
safe and we can serve our customers so i
moved to new hampshire on the very first
day of my job
i would say the vast majority of our
employees are are the same
tell me
the majority of our employees are from
new hampshire and they live within a
half hour drive of lincoln
but what we have
been faced with where we cannot find
enough employees we
are using the h-2b visa program
whereby we are bringing in
anywhere from eight to twelve employees
each season when i see a season it's a
winter and a summer season
and
we've also
increased our beginning wage to eighteen
dollars an hour and
in 2022 we'll pay legal fees
of about forty thousand dollars
for that h-2b program
and we're looking at that and saying
we'd be better off to pay that to the
local
employees
rather than
to
law firms to bring in the foreign
workers
the advantage of the foreign workers you
you get them for six months
and they're they're basically with you
versus in this economy
we find ourselves stealing from each
other we used to steal customers
now we steal employees uh and everybody
has to make a living and
and
sometimes 50 cents an hour
is
that people will leave you but to answer
your question we hire mostly people for
more than a half hour of lincoln
i'd say for us i don't have exact
percentages or anything like that but in
terms of the new employees that we are
hiring it's it's both in the state and
from out of the state we are
like i said we're pretty desperate for
nurses so wherever we can get them
um
we're having to come in my my
mother-in-law had surgery
uh two weeks ago
her nurse had recently moved from from
maine
okay uh
sorry just another comment there
representative talked about the
competition i have in jaffrey with a
large manufacturer who's
trying to hire something like 300 people
uh for a small manufacturer small
business right now
with the the workforce being the way it
is the wage pressure is incredible so um
getting back to your tax questions our
our wages our wage rates are going up to
stay competitive in our local area uh
which means the more we pay for labor
the less profit we have at the end of
the year so you're going to see you know
some mitigating factors i think as wages
go up and we can't raise our prices fast
enough to compensate for all that we're
just going to see profits drop so
another thing to consider when you're
looking at your tax policy
okay no question representative romney
yep this is for you uh
neil
so
one of the
when people ask me what was one of the
top issues over the years i've always
said high energy costs in new hampshire
and they are
and obviously it hasn't gotten any
better
um
we have lint lint chocolate you know my
town of stratum
about five six years ago there was an
editorial and local paper saying these
energy costs are so much they're making
us uncompetitive that to me that was a
shot over the bow
but they stayed and they they continue
to expand which they've been a good
neighbor to us and stratum
they're swiss companies you know
so
but that's there's this backdrop so
but i was interested in hearing more
about this clean clean hydrogen
that you mentioned uh to me hydrogen you
know green energy is all fun and good
but the sony shines you know half today
um and it's all about potential energy
and kinetic energy
and you know when the sun's shining we
have we can have plenty of solar energy
but
but do we use it all you know does it go
to waste so
isn't there a way of converting that
that energy to potential energy in a
form of hydrogen
by
refraction and from water of all sources
uh is that what you had in mind here is
that what you're talking about yeah so
so as an industry across the world
across the world
the gas industry the gas industry during
the 60s repurposed itself from the old
tam gas which interestingly enough uh
hydrogen was involved in that process to
to natural gas
now we're finding that for a whole host
of reasons not least climate change and
decarbonization
the industry is faced with the
opportunity to reinvent itself again
all the way from australia across europe
back to the uk i still have a lot of
colleagues back in the uk each of the
five large utilities in the uk are
working on a separate facet to develop
clean
hydrogen into its gas network
the opportunity for them is
decarbonization the opportunity for us
is is energy independence
with an additional advantage that it
also supports the it also supports the
the climate challenges that we've got so
yeah um
we're looking at an opportunity right
now to work with the mayor and the city
of keene we have a propane air system
out there it's an isolated system
serving about just over a thousand
customers propane air is uh is is a
commodity which isn't very often used
there are no other systems like that in
the entire united states and we're
looking at the opportunity to how do we
develop that particular part of the
world so that so that one um it can be
energy independent
and and two it will also help um the the
mayor out there
achieve his uh his uh you know net zero
climate change ambitions so
hydrogen is is a reality there's lots of
different colored hydrogens um but i
just
you know
to boil the ocean
to boil the ocean it it it is
probably the fastest moving technology
in the gas industry today
there's a lot of places where they're
blending hydrogen into their existing
systems um with a view to 100 hydrogen
in the future so so the technology is a
reality
the reality is it isn't it isn't here in
new hampshire just yet but it's
extracting the hydrogen from water
correct from water yeah using you and i
i see renewable energy sources is a
great source to do that because you need
electricity
to convert it from
that's you do to
separate the oxygen and hydrogen yeah
but then you you have the hydrogen now
is is the energy that that will be used
not not necessarily that the actual
solar energy but it is using solar
energy to convert to
the gas that's clean because there's no
carbons in it no and
okay well i like this idea
that's all i want to say it's it's uh it
excites me it's iced meat too it really
does and it's a huge opportunity for us
okay thank you thank you
their names
yeah briefly uh you don't sit down
this is really an extension of
what you just spoke of i i believe you
also mentioned in your remarks uh uh
projects a project that
looks to enhance ex
extend the use of batteries
and maybe you could talk about that as
well
sure so um so so we've got a pile of
ongoing at the moment for about a
hundred homes um our territory is uh
lebanon and and salem it's about 100
homes it's called a um a tesla powerwall
so we supply a tesla powerwall to a
residential customer they pay us a
nominal monthly fee and throughout the
day energy prices electric prices vary
what they're able to do in again boiling
the ocean is to um is to energize the
battery at a time when uh the
electricity prices are at their lowest
and then when the energy prices are at
their highest they can able to feed off
the battery so it's really good for the
customers and and
it's also a good opportunity for us
because i think once a year we're
allowed to take
um the power out of that battery and
bring it into the system so it helps us
to balance the network if we ever needed
it
the other thing of course is um is you
know we've had a
pretty tough winter we've mobilized our
incident command a few times getting
ready
for potential high winds and everything
else and in the event of an outage you
can use the energy that is stored in
that battery it's really a really great
technology it's another thing i i get
very excited about this industry by the
way
i think you can probably tell
well let me just uh comment that uh i
would say amen to all that
liberty is trying to do and this
this focus on uh
on
energy conceived in a different way than
it has been traditionally
thank you thank you
stay right there
and you elaborated with the hydrogen and
with the battery storage but you you
also mentioned geothermal yeah could you
elaborate how you're involved with the g
yeah so um so in my last role i was head
of gas operations here for national grid
in new england
and
we're working with
with an organization called heat
and heat are environmentalists who are
looking at repurposing the energy
industry and look and looking at the
future of energy and one of the causes
that they champion is the opportunity to
use geothermal heat and uh and actually
there's a number of pilots now ongoing
um with heat and the um and the new
england utilities and what it basically
does is bring heat from within the earth
distributes it through a um
through a pipe network so it's another
really
a great opportunity i haven't had the
opportunity to talk to anybody and and
figure out what that might mean for us
but it's certainly something we should
be considering
represent aaron
thank you mr chair
and yes i have a question for you as
well and i'm a customer in acworth
do i get paid by the question no no
sorry
[Laughter]
no but i um
as well as being on house ways and means
committee i'm also vice chair of
environment and agriculture and we've
been dealing a lot with landfill bills
as you might may or may not know
so i'm interested in your comment before
about
trash to energy
and
interested to know what initiatives
you are working on with that because we
would love to
incorporate that in our study of
landfills and landfill siting and how
how we manage landfills and solid waste
so please let me know what your what you
got in terms of initiatives yes so one
of the one of the one of the first
public opportunities i had in my new
role as president was up in bethlehem
can you speak under the mind sorry yeah
one sorry one of the first opportunities
i had in this job was uh was to head up
to bethlehem where there is a landfill
and uh we are in um you know we've been
working with the company we're
developing that to take the renewable
natural gas and bring it back into our
system
it's great technology it really does
work it supports um it supports our
infrastructure it also
helps us to balance that reliance on
that single pipeline that goes all the
way back to texas so so yeah we you know
i'd be more than happy offline to make
to maybe elaborate a little bit more and
around what we're doing in that space
but but again i have to say i have to
say it is very exciting and
it does technology like this really does
help to create that buffer from the
volatility of these global energy
markets that we are we're suffering from
here in new hampshire
you're welcome
further questions
we'll be right on time thank you thank
you very much
go ahead
thank you representative i just wanted
to close uh two quick uh comments
um first uh we'll follow up to make sure
that members all have the contact
information of the folks who spoke today
in case you have any
follow-up questions
really appreciate the opportunity and i
hope that the dialogue and the
information they shared is
it's indicative of the great talent and
knowledge we have within our business
community and so i would encourage you
going forward whether it's a formal
setting like this or an informal setting
or question if you ever have a question
or want to understand an issue better
please use the bia as a resource
we have a tremendous
membership of business leaders who can
provide
the type of great commentary and
knowledge that you heard here today and
we are
always happy to do that and work with
you and and help you with your jobs of
shaping policy so again we appreciate
the opportunity and look forward to uh
doing again another time thank you
we thank you for
bringing this all together this morning
okay
all right and for the committee members
we'll meet again at one o'clock
because we'll have
bob
the pace and ben frost from the new
hampshire housing finance
authority talk to us
all right good production
we're going to get started
uh
i think some
are still on lunch but they'll be coming
in i hope
this afternoon we're starting a
presentation
ben frost a managing director and
bob the priests
executive director of new hampshire
housing finance authority to discuss the
state's housing market and housing
challenges
bob robbed the priest is the executive
director and ceo of new hampshire
housing
he joined new hampshire housing in 2014
and served in various roles in the
management and development division
overseeing multi-family housing
that was until 2021.
before that the priest was a project
manager for north branch construction he
also was a captain united states army
and served in iraq thank you for your
service
ben frost is the deputy executive
director and chief legal officer for new
hampshire housing
where he manages external relations
legislative initiatives communications
research and strategic planning and
provides legal guidance on program
implementation
and everybody's been handed a
copy of their
colorful presentation so
it's all yours
thank you very much
great
thank you very much mr chairman and uh
and members of the committee i
appreciate your having us here i'm
i'm rob and i appreciate the
introductions as well
so we're pleased to join you today to
share some of our observations and
insights into what's happening in the
housing market in new hampshire before
we do that i'm going to
provide a little bit of background in
case some of you may not be as familiar
with our organization
we are a self-supporting public benefit
corporation so we were established by
state law about 40 years ago with a
mission to
create
and support the creation of affordable
housing and related services for the
people of new hampshire we're not state
employees we don't receive any operating
money from the state we are entrusted
with the administration of the
affordable housing fund and a variety of
resources federal and state level
resources
to help carry out that mission
ben's going to talk a lot about what we
are observing in the housing market this
slide provides a little bit of
background into what we're trying to do
about the housing market in new
hampshire so we have operational
divisions that run programs that
help make home ownership accessible and
available to low and middle income new
hampshire residents we have a
multi-family rental housing division
that helps
finance refinance and preserve
affordable apartment buildings across
the state
and our assisted housing division helps
some of new hampshire's most vulnerable
citizens with rental assistance vouchers
and related services
in addition to that
we've been administering a range of
emergency response programs on behalf of
the state
early in the pandemic we ran the shelter
modification program funded with cares
act dollars which
used about 12 million dollars to help
shelters across the state adapt their
physical spaces to be safer uh in
in
light of the pandemic and also to pay
for
ppe and things like that as they adapted
for that first pandemic affected winter
more recently we've been working in
cooperation with the governor's office
for emergency relief and recovery and
the cap agencies on the emergency rental
assistance program
and we're also the contractor
for the state for the homeowner
assistance fund
which helps people who have fallen
behind on their mortgage payments or
property taxes during the pandemic and
that will be launching soon
all those programs are funded by
federal grant programs including the
american rescue plan and some related
recent spending bills
so
those are important programs
especially now as we've seen a number of
changes in the housing market in new
hampshire over the last couple of years
new hampshire had a challenging
environment before the pandemic and it's
gotten a lot tougher and that's affected
just about everybody who's looking for a
place to buy or rent where they want to
live it certainly has affected
low and middle income new hampshire
residents even more
and that is who we primarily serve
so we appreciate the opportunity to
speak with you today ben's going to go
through some content that talks about
some of those changes some of them
we understand the factors
that are driving them and some of them
are just beginning to get our arms
around but
after he speaks we'll wrap it up and be
happy to answer any questions
thank you
thank you rob uh good morning everyone
or
good afternoon that's the second time
i've done that
um
really happy to be back with you uh in
person
uh in in this different room for from
what we normally meet but uh happy to
see your faces and i i think we have
some members online as well
um i'm going to start talking about the
housing market and i've done a number of
these these presentations uh before and
the question i i usually have as a
headline is
what's happening with the housing market
uh certainly that's a really good
question because
uh some unexpected things happened
during
the covet emergency
certainly caught a lot of people by
surprise
things seem to be returning to something
that's a little bit more normal now
but it is it is indeed a new normal
where we have very high prices both in
the rental and the purchase market i'm
going to start talking about the the
residential rental market trends
and note that all of these slides and
i'll and you have those of you have the
paper copies i'm on slide four
all of the data we have here presented
to you regarding the rental market is
based upon our annual residential rental
cost survey so these are 2021 data
we are in the midst of our 2022
residential rental cost survey so
we're we annually survey something on
the order of 20 to 25 000 units
across the state
and then we
pair it down to get a a controllable
size of
roughly 12 000 units
and this is responses we get from the
landlords on what they're charging
tenants and what their tenants are
paying in utilities and we control for
utilities so so we were able to discern
the difference between situations where
tenants are paying the utilities or
where the landlord is paying utilities
so we're in the midst of doing that and
we should have the 2022 numbers
available publicly
probably in early july so this is a long
survey
and very very comprehensive and we work
with the unh survey center and others to
develop the data for us
and we've been doing this survey since
the early 90s and in our view it's it's
the best source of information on the
rental market in the state and is i
think peerless
among among all states in the country in
the quality of the data
but looking at um the the costs and this
is really what everyone's talking about
the rental costs are high if you look at
slide 4 you see
the the median gross rent that's rent
plus utilities
statewide is almost fifteen hundred
dollars that was last year it'll be
certainly be higher this year
uh and
uh for
all units that's for two bedroom units
for all units it's uh thirteen hundred
seventy three so
um recognizing that the bulk the vast
bulk of units statewide are two-bedroom
units that's really a particularly
important factor for us to look at then
looking at the the trends over time
we see
significant changes between 2020 and
and also in five years roughly you know
20 to 25 percent increases over five
years
and we recognize too that
as these prices have gone up for renters
their incomes have not kept pace
so say 20 to 25 percent increases in
rents and roughly over that same period
of time a six percent
increase in median renter income
it's getting tougher and tougher for
renters to afford regardless of their
incomes and regardless of where they are
in the state
moving on to uh slide five this is the
uh this is kind of the flip side of what
we look at in terms of of the the rental
market the vacancy rate uh what's
available for people who are looking for
a place and this is a story that we read
almost every day in the headlines and
newspapers um
that
it's hard to find a place to rent
regardless of your income because
there's just not much out there
all over the state
so vacancy rate of residential rental
units uh all of
for all units is below one percent point
nine for two bedroom units uh is point
six percent that that's stunningly low
uh
and you and you're looking looking at
the graph you can see
uh there's variation from year to year
but if we were to draw a trend line you
can see it trending downward
and that is not a good sign for the the
rental market it's not good sign for
renters
if you happen to be a landlord great
good for you because you've got your
choice of of who you can rent to uh and
you know certainly for for anyone who
has attempted to rent uh in this market
uh it is difficult but from from a
landlord's perspective it's really great
um i just anecdotally
my wife's daughter was looking for a
place to live outside of portland maine
very similar housing market to what
we're experiencing here in new hampshire
and
she could not find a place to rent in
the greater portland area something that
she could reasonably afford um and so we
we ultimately helped her buy a house it
was actually easier to buy a small house
for her than to find a place to rent
which
is difficult do you mind if we interrupt
questions or do you want to please do
okay uh representative brandi thank you
mr chair thank you both
uh back to slide four when you said you
said i'm gonna make sure i understood
what you said
these are the rents including utilities
yes and those would be heat and well
electricity and heat yes okay thank you
and then on the one year the page you're
on right now
the uh
page five
so
that decline is is unique is new
hampshire unique in this or is this the
trend you're seeing around the country
as well this is a trend around the
country generally speaking uh i'd say
it's particularly acute in
some markets so the
boston
met greater metro area
which includes southern new hampshire
but extending throughout new hampshire
into southern maine and you see it in
other
other markets that are influenced by
larger urban areas certainly we hear a
lot about san francisco uh which is you
know san francisco and boston compete
for the the toughest housing market in
the country um so this this is a
national issue and nationally we do see
that there's a dearth of housing
available
in
important markets for people to rent or
to buy
thank you
representative janisian
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for coming and presenting
this to us today um what is what would
you consider a normal vacancy rate
that's an excellent question and uh we
can skip ahead to slide seven oh and
i'll do that just for these purposes and
and jennifer thank you for advancing
that looking at the vacancy rate by
county
um
you can see what we generally consider
to be a balanced renter rental market
that is balancing the interests of uh
tenants and of landlords to be something
on the order of five percent
um three percent we generally regard as
turnover rate that is the time it takes
for a landlord to prep a unit between
tenants uh and we have been below three
percent
for
seven or eight years a long time and if
you look at it county by county
it's pretty uh uniform throughout the
state even in
counties where you consider incomes to
be lower
kawasa county uh in particular you see
that the vacancy rate is extremely low
uh it's
there's just not enough out there for
folks
uh now if we can move back to slide six
and that was a great question thank you
uh
just looking at the the the rents county
to county
um
you we know that you know the
southeastern portion of the state the
southern tier of the state is really
that where the the hot market is it's
also where most people live uh the four
counties merrimack hillsborough
stratford and and rockingham county
constitute about 75 percent of the the
state's population
and that's really where we see that the
hottest rental market rockingham county
has the highest median at uh 1672 that's
again last year's figures
and the changes over time are pretty
significant so
you know rockingham county over a
five-year period from 2016 to 2021 the
rent went up 26
um even in koas county it went up 11
over that five-year period and depending
upon how you look at it um
you might say well there's you know a
um
say uh more units may be more affordable
in coast county but you're not going to
be commuting uh from uh say berlin uh
well not too many people would from from
berlin uh down to a job in in you know
the portsmouth area to manchester or
concord that's a pretty long drive some
people some people in this room may
actually make that commute i don't know
but most people would not be willing to
do that
so even though the the rents are lower
in cost county
relative to the incomes of the people
who live there it's also a pretty
unaffordable place
so let's move to
um
the last slide on the renter market
that's slide eight and this gets to that
the point i was just making about the
relative affordability county to county
so you can see in kawasa county and
cheshire county the rents are somewhat
more affordable
to people making the median renter
income
for that county but still
the median is the the halfway mark of
the population so
in in even in cowas county you've got 23
percent of the units that are affordable
for 50 of the population
that's renting
it is an unaffordable market even there
statewide 13 only 13
of the units in the renter market
that is
whether they're occupied by by tenants
now or on the market 13 are affordable
to the the median renter market
statewide that it is a really tough
market to be a renter
now unless there any
more questions on the renter market we
can move on to the
the purchase market
and look at home ownership activity
so we're on slide 10 now
and
again this this
graph shows uh pretty stark numbers um
from
for a number of uh times that we were
doing these this presentation we were
looking at you know annual changes and i
thought
well maybe we should be looking at a
two-year change look to pre-covet and to
current
information so january 2020
the median sales price statewide was 280
january of 2022
385 000
that's a 38 increase over two years
that's pretty shocking and you know
incomes have not kept pace it's tough to
find a place that is affordable to buy
not just to rent but to buy as well and
you can see this this curve
uh really accelerating with the
beginning of the pandemic and this was
at the outside i talked about what's
happening with the housing market that's
that question this is what caught us by
surprise
mr chairman
yeah how much of this
38 percent was associated with the
pandemic
with people
from like the boston new york they're
coming into new hampshire buying up
that's an excellent question you know
i'll i'll say
we have another slide coming up that
addresses where people are coming from
but it doesn't answer that question
fully
uh and this is a question that we are
puzzling over ourselves
and a lot of people are and we'll be
attempting to answer it for some time to
come as we as the data get better and as
we look have a better historical
perspective representative aaron thank
you mr chair and as a follow-up to what
you're saying i mean i know in sullivan
county uh i've spoken to the the
registrar of deeds
and she said you know
real estate has just been snapped up
uh sight unseen by people from out of
state
they will call her and or call real
estate agents and say you know do you
have a property that has x y z
and sight unseen by it
at prices that
we've never seen in our county
so i think that's really starting to
make you know the raise in in these uh
prices of these homes and properties i
think
i i agree with you completely and uh it
and we've heard lots of stories we um
because we do home ownership lending too
and so we hear stories about uh from our
the lenders and the realtors uh that
people are buying things without
contingencies they're waiving the home
inspections they're buying cash and if
you're if you're a first-time home buyer
if you're you've got you know lots of
student loans and you don't have a
really big down payment
if if you're seeking mortgage approval
and you're face to face
competing with a cash buyer the seller
is going to want to take that cash buyer
yeah mr chair follow-up yeah and you
know one of the things they're
mentioning is that the folks who are
coming from out of state
these prices that they're paying here
are still so affordable and cheap
in comparison to what they're selling in
their uh
states they're coming from yes so
particularly
the boston uh uh you know close to metro
area uh if you're looking at properties
in in in brooklyn or waltham
um they're they're twice the cost of
what you could uh purchase in new
hampshire and maybe get twice the home
in new hampshire
so it is a it's a
it's a tough market it's a great if
you're a seller
as long as you have a place to move to
representative almay
thank you uh
are you going to be able to see
how much our renter to homebuyer home
owner
on
ratio has changed
with all of this buying
because there's persistent rumors at
least of based on things like that
that people are buying just in order
to hold rent for high prices and flip
and not planning on moving here
that that's a great question
yes we will be able to do that but it
will take some time for us to be able to
develop the data and and i think
in addition to people
speculatively purchasing in anticipation
of flipping the the properties for
profit
which you know it
this is the way the market operates
there are also those people
or
more institutional investors
who will purchase properties with the
intention of holding them for the long
run and renting them
so there is an increasing market
nationally and i think
eventually it will come here to new
hampshire as well we haven't seen it
that much but nationally where we have
larger
institutional investors purchasing
properties for the purpose of holding
them and renting them out and there so
there is an increasing market for the
rental of freestanding single-family
homes on individual lots
now back to slide 10
if you look at the very tail the right
tail of this this curve the blue line
you can see how it has smoothed out a
bit uh it and and
at the outset when when i started
talking i talked about the
returning to some sort of new normal we
have seen home prices not coming down
but stabilizing a bit in the last couple
of months which suggests that we are
returning to something
more
normal in terms of seasonal activity
typically speaking we see
home sales activity falling off in
november december january february and
then picking up for the spring market
that did not happen
in in 2020
winter 2020 into 2021 in fact that was a
really hot season
but coming into this winter season we've
seen it slowing down a bit which may be
attributable to the lack of inventory
which we'll talk about in a moment
may be attributable to increasing
interest rates as well uh putting a
something of a damper on the market we
don't anticipate prices coming down
um but they have stabilized a little bit
into something more of a seasonal
activity that we we typically see in the
blue line you can see that the seasonal
fluctuations in prices and we seem to be
coming into that now
moving on to
slide 11 this is the flip side of this
story supply and demand
the
the inventory of housing that is
available on the market and this is this
uh these these curves the blue line and
the orange dotted line or dashed line
indicate how long it would take for
everything that's currently on the
market
to sell at the preceding 12 months pace
of sales activity so it's an indication
of of the capacity of the market to meet
current demand
and we generally regard something on the
a six month sub inventory to be a
balanced market like in the the renter
market this is a market six percent or
six months inventory balances the
interests of buyers and sellers
approximately it's not a it's not a hard
science to it but it's an approximate
number we've been we've been below six
months of inventory since 2016 or before
that
um and we are now down below one month
in inventory and if you look at the data
that's available from the new hampshire
association of realtors as well you see
time on market time on market of things
coming onto the market is now
under a month which is
it's just it's shocking how hot this
market is it's not quite as hot as it
was maybe six months ago or a year ago
it's not red red red hot or white hot
it's just hot it's still hot market
and
recognized too that with these this this
balance between supply and demand we saw
that on the preceding slide with with
the prices uh this really impacts those
people who are attempting to enter home
ownership mr chairman
representative brown you know another
question thanks um
so the blue line oscillation is that
seasonal is that the seasonal aspect
okay that is seasonal yes thank you
now moving on to um
slide 12.
this is the the actual sales activity
the the numbers of properties
residential properties
sold
and these are
for the past three years now moving
january to the past four years
we see that the
tempering of activity in january this of
january 2022 in comparison to january
despite the very low inventory um we
we're seeing uh an extraordinary pace of
sales which suggests increasing prices
but also that time on market coming down
so things were selling very fast um it
seems to have reached a point where the
market just can't accommodate the need
for those additional sales and so in
fact we're seeing fewer and fewer sales
because there's just not enough out
there for people to buy and this is the
story we've been hearing for a number of
months maybe the last year and a half
from realtors there's just not enough
inventory for them uh to sell to their
their customers their their clients
they're the people who want to buy a
home
and so while if you look at the the
december activity the middle bar in
december uh that is 2021
and and that's that that high level of
activity that i was talking about the
unusually
high winter activity it seems to have
come down now in in 2022 in this this
season
next slide is slide 13 and this is
really a
big part of the story
uh in the sales market the mortgage
interest rates
and you see over time this goes back to
2000 uh how far down the interest rates
have come
and we have circled uh december 2020
in its circle for a reason at two point
six eight percent
uh this was uh the lowest
uh that interest rates nationally have
ever been recorded this is a freddie mac
survey of uh
national survey of
major mortgage lenders and the interest
rates they're charging and freddie mac
has been doing this survey since 1972
and this is uh the lowest they ever
recorded uh it has come up since then
and there certainly is
news from the fed that they're planning
to do additional interest rate increases
um and so that that is part of the the
tempering activity that we see going on
with with the market right now but
there's still a lot of activity and
especially as there's the
threat or the perception of a threat of
increased uh
interest rates will drive additional
activity too people need to buy now
before the interest rates go up and so
as much as they can they're they're
engaging in that activity so you see now
we're up to uh 3.45 percent and that's
the um
the highest it's been since um
uh 2020. uh and then going back it's uh
it's still 3.45 percent is not too bad
now looking at
this is a fairly detailed slide i'm not
going to go through all of this you can
read it at your leisure if you have
questions later on please feel free to
send them to us
but this is
looking at mortgage lending in new
hampshire this is the mortgage bankers
association data
from december of 2021 note that
80 percent
of all applications for mortgages in
december of 2021 were for refinancing
and that's that that threat that i
talked about the threat of increased
interest rates
you know you know honey we've got to act
now we've got to re-fire our home we've
got to get it down from 4.5 percent to
3.5 percent
and you know if you plan to stay in your
home for a long time then that that's a
good deal for you you can cover the cost
of closing and save over the long run
that said if you compare and there's a
typo on the slide it should read this is
in the middle of the page december 2020
to december 2021 not december 19 but
december 2020 to december 21 we see a
drop
in the refi activity and a
slight increase in the purchase activity
overall
and that is i think
an indication that
much of the refi
activity that we have seen has been
exhausted
that is those people who were going to
refi have done it and so as the interest
rates go up they're saying okay we've
we've done what we can with our with our
refi of our home uh we're not going to
do it again
and representative amy you asked about
the
the flipping behavior
and
here's some information on this in the
middle of this page investor purchase
mortgage versus you know second home
purchase mortgage
it's still relatively low in those
investors those people those people or
organizations who are not intending to
occupy the home uh but to rent it out uh
or to hold it and flip it or whatever
lower in new hampshire than we see
nationally so but not a whole lot lower
nationally 6.3 percent near new
hampshire 5.1 percent
and then second home purchases
much higher 50 percent higher here in
new hampshire well if you think about
the activity we see in uh in the lakes
region the mount washington valley parts
of the north country yeah that makes a
lot of sense there especially in in
carroll county uh where we see i think
it's 48
of the homes 48 of all
owner occupied homes
are in fact vacant meaning they're owned
by someone as a second home
48 in carroll county mount washington
valley
and that is the highest in the state
and then just looking at the uh the
percentage of purchase mortgages versus
refi mortgages at the bottom and the
distribution among the different types
of
mortgage products they're using
now moving on to mortgage delinquencies
this is i think a particularly
interesting slide this is a comparison
of the unemployment rate the orange
curve and mortgage delinquencies and it
it's it's what you would expect to see
as people lose their jobs
and we see this at the beginning of the
pandemic where the unemployment rate
in new hampshire and nationally shot up
really fast
we saw a uh an increase in delinquencies
but it has really come down um as the
economy has improved people as people
have gone back to work as they've
figured out how to deal with their their
financial situations and as the
unemployment rate has come down you know
we are the i think the second lowest
unemployment rate in the country at uh
2.7 percent um
and
moving on now to um slide 16 and uh uh
mr chairman this this is the question
you were asking before about you know uh
what's the impact of out-of-state buyers
where are where are these people coming
from who are buying in new hampshire uh
whether it's
whether they're buying in sullivan
county or they're buying in rockingham
county where are they coming from
um and there's especially if you're if
you're reading the headlines you say
well there are these hordes of people
coming across the border from
massachusetts and and snapping up homes
and from one neighborhood to another
from one town to another that may be
that may be true but if you look at the
overall patterns
there has been some increase
in the proportion of buyers in
particular from massachusetts
but still most of the buyers here in new
hampshire are already here
in fact
the middle point here in italics most
buyers are local to their own markets
not just statewide but people generally
speaking who are buying in new hampshire
are already in
the the housing markets where they're
buying they're selling one home buying
another or they're moving up from being
a renter to buying a home within the
existing housing market where they
already live
that said there are some some regional
influences that are really important
that drive this activity from other
states
in particular from from massachusetts
the the pull
of the upper valley dartmouth college
and
and dh health and other associated
organizations in the area a lot of
high-tech activity that's been spun off
from the um
the incubator there
uh the pull of the lakes region the pull
of the mountains and i'll call it
maybe this is improper to say but the
repulsive or the propulsive influence of
boston because of its cost
so it's pushing people
out away from boston into new hampshire
and new hampshire is a particularly
attractive place to be so why wouldn't
they come here and they do so those are
some influences that influence you know
particular markets uh so we see a lot of
activity uh in uh the in the upper
valley where there is a relatively
higher proportion of mortgage purchases
than there is statewide and i think
that's the the impact of those the
industries they are pulling people to
the upper valley and then of course
there's the second home purchasers in
the lakes region and in the mountains
the next slide here we're talking really
just about population trends and we've
heard about
and this is drawing on the work that uh
ken johnson from the car seat school has
done
now the population growth in new
hampshire and i changed the title here i
had said
modest and i said slow and it's both
modest and slow population growth
you know we're growing by you know
something on the order of 5 000 people a
year
which is a a sharp uh difference from
how new hampshire was growing say 20
years ago when we were growing between
50 and 20 000 people a year a new
laconia every year in new hampshire not
so much anymore it's more like
a new new boston every year
but still
there is growth going on most of this
now and and this is uh influenced by
what we see in the boston metro area is
growth in the millennial population the
largest uh generation when you talk
about the baby boomer and how big the
baby boomer population was well the
millennial uh generation is actually the
largest uh generational group that we
see so they're entering into this
market where they're purchasing homes
now starting
at maybe a later age than their their
prior generations had but they are
purchasing homes and they're moving to
places where they want to work and where
they want to live and that includes new
hampshire
but recognize that even as new hampshire
is the fastest growing state in new
england
new england and the northeast as overall
is a slow growing region so we're the
fastest in this in the slowest growing
region in the country
it is buoyed a bit i say by
international uh immigration uh and and
they'd say that's a good thing
oftentimes we we see people coming to
new hampshire who are uh bringing a lot
of talent uh to our industries and to
our communities
um and that is an influence i think that
is pretty positive
some other growth that's going on and
and this is i think particularly in the
early days of the pandemic we were
reading about it in places like
waterville valley and the mount
washington valley people
coming to occupy the second homes that
they already owned or the third or
fourth or fifth homes that they already
owned
and bring their kids with them because
the kids were learning remotely anyway
so why not go to the ski condo and the
kids can you know be at school
during the school days and then they can
go out to the slopes
that that happened a lot and we saw a
dramatic increase in the waterville
valley school population for that year i
think i i've not
seen the actual numbers yet but i know
that for the mount washington valley
that has come back down to something
more normal this year
but
to the extent
some of that is
a trend that sticks
and this is a question how sticky are
these trends going to be
those will have some implications for
local school budgets in those areas
and because people already own those
homes it's not reflected in sales
activity
the last thing i have here before i turn
it back over to rob is the building
permit activity
this is a big part of the story of the
housing market in new hampshire
and we see going back to 2000 you see
the level of activity that we had in the
blue line is single family homes uh the
orange line is uh multi-family
construction which is highly variable
year to year uh but if we were to do a
trend line on the single family homes
you'd see a lot of activity going on in
the early part
of the the 2000s but then with the great
recession it dropped off precipitously
and has not really recovered it's been i
call it a slim recovery and you see it
trending upward but it's still nothing
like uh the activity in building that we
saw in the early part of the 2000s
now
the big question is why
why aren't builders building more why is
why don't we have more construction um
and that's that's a question that we're
wrestling with uh right now and part of
it is you know part of its local
regulation that we have to address
and that that's it for the the market
i'm going to turn it back to rob now to
um
do a few more
closing comments but i think
ben would you take another question
certainly representative alamedy
thank you
when i came home
i remember being told that when we had
the major crash for new hampshire in the
1990 1991
that a whole lot of construction
companies just gave up
and disappeared and that after that
they learned
not to build on spec
anymore and
i'm kind of surprised actually that we
got up to that level of building in the
early 2000s i didn't even
notice it in lebanon much
that that's a great point representative
and
you're right uh for new hampshire the
the you know 1990 that was our great
recession and we saw
a lot of banks
go into bankruptcy and go away
you know think of all the names of banks
that no longer exist in new hampshire
and
with them a lot of builders who
for a variety of reasons decided not to
continue building here in new hampshire
we had a very
high surplus of housing in new hampshire
in the first part of that decade but
that surplus was eaten up by 1995.
and starting in 1995 we saw the prices
of homes in new hampshire start to
accelerate again and as a result we see
that we saw that activity of home
construction in the early 2000s
which was
really a response to that demand
that for for new homes so i'm not sure
that there was a lot of spec building
going on in the early 2000s
but there there was a very high demand
and we did not see uh you know
tremendously high vacancy rates as a
result of the recession these homes were
occupied people might have been
underwater and so that they might have
been compelled to stay in their homes
but they were in their homes
and it just has not recovered part of
the reason you're right is that there's
insufficient skilled labor
to do this and an insufficient number of
smaller scale developers which is the
kind of development we have seen we see
in new hampshire we don't have the
massive builders that we see in other
parts of the of the country
we have smaller developers building
smaller developments
next with
representative romney followed by
representative aaron i just want to
continue on this theme
okay so we know
background
interest rates are low
positive
demand is high positive
but still no one's building right
i mean let's just list the negatives
right i mean the cost of the dirt is a
lot
i mean if you're you're you're a bent
builder that that costs a lot so you're
not going to tend to build something
cheap you're going to build something
big
i would imagine to get return
you'd be mentioned
the skilled labor is not there
now now
in the last year cost the materials just
i mean it really went up
now has that come back down a little bit
do you guys know
i hear rumors that it's come down from
its peaks of what a what a
piece of plywood costs or a 2x4 but
thank you representative yeah certainly
the cost of lumber peaked uh last year
and has come down substantially but what
we have not seen uh improved is the
supply chain interruptions that have
really bedeviled builders so things like
appliances and garage doors we've had a
number of projects that have been
beset by delays and those kinds of
deliveries that can result in a
certificate of occupancy being delayed
by a couple of months it's happening on
the single family side as well
and as everybody knows time is money in
the construction business and so it's
really uh driven up cost for the
builders which is passed right down to
consumer
yeah my follow-up
i mean in my town we had
treat farms we have we still have some
farms but you know they eventually
either they go into conservation
or a builder
you know an um developer
buys up the property
and they built 18 our homes large but
big homes
not little teeny homes big homes oh just
about everyone was over a million
dollars
and they they were gobbled up
like you know the sign went up 18 lots
available
i drove by like a couple weeks later it
was pretty much all sold
so i i guess that's
i mean i i guess these guys had no
problem no choice but to buy build big
homes to get the return on their
investment but i mean are you seeing
this kind of thing i mean i'm just
yeah we are and i think the point about
larger homes still being built there's
still a very strong market for large
homes
make no mistake about that
but in in many communities that's all
builders can build because of the
regulatory environment that they're
they're presented
so
they don't have the choice of building
large or small even though there is a
significantly growing market for smaller
homes smaller lots right doesn't mean
doesn't mean that there isn't still a
market for large homes there is
but there is also this growing market
for smaller homes but developers just
can't build it because the regulations
don't allow it right and i right and
that was the other thing the regulations
we've heard this before about the
regulations being an issue in town to
town
thank you
representative aaron thank you mr chair
and
most of what mr representative ramy said
i was going to say but also
i want to
ask you
for this the slide that you had i guess
number 18
the new new hampshire building permits
lagging
is included in that is also
any kind of modular homes
versus
you know like
for real new construction because every
single time i'm driving back to acworth
from concord i'm seeing these modular
homes on the on the road
presumably being delivered somewhere in
new hampshire
so
it seems to me there's there's
a lot of activity for that
there is and and i i agree i i've done
from warner so i'm you know i see them
coming along they see half half of a
house or a quarter of a house or uh you
know truly modular homes
so
just to distinguish legally
a modular home would count as a
single-family home manufactured housing
which is
legally different
would not be included in this total here
but
but there is a really strong market for
that as well thank you
representatives
thank you mr chair so have land use
local regulations change dramatically in
the past 20 years
well
[Music]
i'd say they've
changed
over a longer period of time than that
and
what we've
seen
over the past say 30 to 40 years is a
gradual tightening
of the land use regulations
as
local boards have become
more sophisticated uh more knowledgeable
about what the
their legal constraints are so they're
acting
in many cases legally
but they're doing so in such a way that
prevents a broader range of development
from happening
follow-up
i'm just looking at your graph and
basically you know things were really
sparking along there 2000 2001 was only
20 years ago right and then they fell
off a cliff
so the regulations haven't changed but
the implementation has been the thing
i think that's that's a good observation
yes implementation has changed as as
boards have gotten more as i say more
sophisticated and how they're using
their regulations
but
this is also influenced by the lack of
builders the cost of materials a variety
of different factors um one of the
things
a point that we've made a number of
times is that
there are certain factors we can't
control we can't control the cost of
materials we can't control the cost of a
two by four coming from wherever it's
coming from but the local regulations is
something we can
influence and control and so that's why
we focus on that so much
representative alame
thank you i'd like to throw something
else into the mix that i don't think
we've talked about
but we deal with in lebanon
a lot and
other places do too
on
water and sewer systems
they were built mostly at the turn of
the previous century
they have been falling apart and they
also are in a lot of places
near
capacity
on
and
they are in the core areas
that
on
that are restricted into how much land
is left
that you can build in unless
you can convince your constituents to
allow
towers
as versus single-family homes and uh
that's pretty difficult
do you do you think that the water sewer
costs of upgrades which are huge uh
we've been doing this for some time now
and we're going to be doing it for the
next 50 years
is part of this
i'm sorry is is what
is part of oh yes this
this problem of having to restrict to
the areas that have water and sewer now
but not to overload them
it is part of it and in fact we
recognize that the the presence of
public water and public sewer systems
is important i don't want to say
essential but it is important
for
increasing the housing supply because
that's where you can do denser
development and i i would i would say it
doesn't have the alternatives are not
single-family homes and towers there are
some things in between as well
that can be accommodated
by municipalities with public water and
sewer
without you know
substantially changing the character of
their communities
thank you
sorry
so i'll provide a few concluding
comments before i do that while we're
still looking at this building permits
slide i just wanted to add one other
thought with respect to your question
representative irf and i think that is
it would be a mistake to assume that
because 20 years ago there was a robust
pace of construction that at that time
communities had zoning regulations that
were appropriate to keep pace with the
rate of growth that was occurring
you know i've heard people say their
community is built out and while that
may be somewhat true based on their
current zoning and 30 000 square foot
minimum lot sizes you know every one of
those 30 000 foot
lots could accommodate
more units than is currently being
accommodated on it so it may just be
that the capacity based on the current
zoning regulations which have been in
place for some decades
has been absorbed and so the market's
ability to respond to the increased
demand
is no longer there
uh thank you so
i believe this is our last our last
content rich slide and so i'll
as i said provide a few other comments
on the topic of interest rates i wanted
to actually provide a little bit of
additional sort of late breaking news
and more recent developments and it's
hard to see
exactly where this will go from here but
you know
historically low interest rates of
course are a double-edged sword because
they help with affordability uh they're
great if you're selling a house as ben
said
um
but uh they they fuel the runaway uh
home price increases that have made it
so hard for people to
afford houses uh there it's sort of
commonly understood that increases that
you hear about in the headlines
from the federal reserve will sort of uh
advance in lockstep in terms of home
mortgage lending rates that's not
necessarily true it has a lot to do with
uh the flow of capital and so the
uncertainty that we're seeing
internationally the tragic events in
ukraine have resulted in a lot of
capital wanting to come out of equities
out of the stock market and back into
what's perceived as safer investments in
bonds and mortgage revenue bonds and so
we've actually seen just over the last
couple of weeks a marked decline in uh
in mortgage rates not back to where they
were in december 2020
but if the uncertainty persists then it
could be with that we're headed back
into record territory in terms of uh in
terms of interest rates
so
a number of these uh topics have already
been covered and i won't uh belabor the
points about the low inventory and and
the the ways in which this problem has
been some decades in the making i just
wanted to sort of uh bring it back with
a couple of comments that may be
somewhat outside of the scope of this
presentation but i think are important
for understanding it
you know after a similar presentation
five or six years ago where
the slide about the percentage of
apartment units that were affordable to
the median renter household was shown at
that time it was nowhere near as bad you
saw today it's 13 percent statewide i
think at that time it was 20 or 25
percent of the apartment units and
somebody
at my table said that makes no sense i
live in uh franklin and i drive to
concord all the time and i see
uh all these apartment buildings are
full so somebody's affording something
and of course he's right the apartment
buildings are full and people are
finding ways to make it work but i think
what you don't see when you drive by an
apartment building with a full parking
lot is that
increasing number of renters and
homeowners and particularly new home
buyers are cost burdened
that standard in terms of affordability
was based on a long-standing federal
standard uh that 30 of one's income is
an appropriate amount to spend for rent
and increasingly we see this uh on our
uh in our home mortgage lending and you
see it across the industry that more and
more people have uh debt to income
ratios approaching 50 percent
and what that means in terms of our
communities is that
those those households are less
financially resilient they're less able
to respond when
inflation occurs when gas prices go up
to three
350 or four dollars per gallon uh
increasingly they have longer commutes
that have
attended costs child care challenges
that in turn affects our labor force
participation rate and makes it
more difficult for our businesses to be
competitive
so
i've been at new hampshire housing for
seven years
we do housing and we've always seen this
as a problem that's important to solve i
think
never more than today have we seen how
interrelated it is with our uh with our
state's economic vitality and
competitiveness
uh and and and also the public health of
our citizens and and i know that you and
many of your colleagues appreciate that
as well and that's reflected in some of
the activity in the legislature that's
designed to address the housing crisis
so
we appreciate that work and we
appreciate your time today and we're
happy to answer any other questions you
may have
so
opera money
so we got about half we've only
encumbered about half of the billion
dollars so there's 500 million
kind of sitting there waiting for some
place to go
you have any ideas
uh we do and what helped us spend this
money and so does the governor uh so
we were pleased with the governor's
announcement in the state of the state
speech for the invest new hampshire fund
which is okay uh 100 million dollars uh
that he's intending to use the fiscal
recovery funds for
uh so
uh we expect more details soon on
exactly sort of the details of that
program but that represents a
significant investment in in uh creating
new housing so you you folks be involved
with that a bit is that
i believe so we're sort of working with
the
uh
governor's office on learning more of
those details all right thank you
thank you so there goes one there goes
one-fifth of what was left
right there
thank you
representation
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
presentation today
um
i just forgot what my question was
i'm sorry i'll have to
okay
representing almi yeah i was counting up
while the governor was speaking and he
spent just about all of that 500 000
i think about 200 i mean million about
200 million of it was something that jeb
bradley was going to do
okay okay
uh representations
thank you and thank you both for all the
amazingly good work you're doing
um
so i've been sitting here puzzling over
why
you know the big question why
why are things so tight housing is so
tight
um down
you know these slow these numbers that
you've gone over
and um
and uh at the same time our population
isn't that much greater
um
and we probably got as much housing as
we used to have
and probably a little bit more um
and um
so we've got uh people buying houses as
second homes that's going on and maybe
there's a short-term housing
activity going on that's
taking uh
sort of residential housing out and
replacing it with uh transit people are
going moving through and just here first
for vacation or whatever
um
and then there's the differentials
within the
housing market of
the high end and the low end and uh the
workforce
uh place
and um
it just doesn't all add up to me maybe
you can uh
try to
help me understand so that so that we
can
look
sensibly at interventions and i know
that's much too big a question but
maybe you could take a whack at it
a household formula for formation is
another thing the size of households
um
if more people are scrunching into
a two-bedroom unit then uh
you know you need less housing i guess
if more people feel
each each of them has to have their own
unit then
um that leads you to a totally different
count of housing needed
you have a question that's it i'd just
like them to speak to this larger
question of why okay
we could mr chair if you'd like we could
certainly uh
respond uh to to that comment and
i guess i would just say representative
ames uh thank you for those uh
for your kind words and and for your
comments i think the the last point that
you made is actually a very important
one which is about household size and
new hampshire housing did a study in
essentially predicting this trend and
observing the change in household size
and so
while our population and our housing
stock has increased over the last couple
of decades uh you know in in the 70s and
80s there were far more households where
there was a family of six or seven
living in a in a three or four bedroom
house
or in some cases a smaller house and and
so that's one housing unit and six or
seven people it's far more likely today
that you'll have
uh three or four households among those
six or seven people if that makes sense
and so the number of housing units
has not kept pace uh even though you're
correct that it has grown uh as our
population has grown
okay
we are out of time on this
and if you have any further questions
i've talked to them on the side
because we do have schedule at two
o'clock
to listen to the director of division of
public health and services
so i'm going to stick to the timetable
and we thank you very much i mean it's
very informative i'm sure that we could
keep you here for quite a while longer
so
thank you as ben said we're we
appreciate your time and we're available
for questions so represent aaron if you
want to grab them
on the side
yeah
okay
patricia tilly
well they're getting that ready patricia
tilley is the deputy director of the
division of public health services
department of health and human services
she's going to discuss the
panoramic
pandemic conditions of the state and the
status of vaccine distribution
now patricia tilley
besides being the director
of the department of health and health
human services she's been in state
service for more than 20 years in
various roles
all designed to protect and promote the
health and well-being of all new
hampshire residents
she has helped lead the new hampshire
public health coverage response
including as a public health advisor to
the governor's economic reopening
committee in the early days of the
pandemic
so is now yours partition
thank you so much chair and to the rest
of the committee thank you so much i
realize i'm in the unenviable position
of being last on what was probably a
very long day i'm glad you have the
window the curtains closed there because
the sun is beautiful outside even though
it is still quite chilly
so it's not quite spring although it
feels like it
before i begin i just want to note that
much of our work in public health is
only possible with the support and
engagement of all of our policy makers
you make our budgets
and you hold us accountable and
throughout the pandemic the health of
many new hampshire residents and the
health of our businesses and the health
of our health care system has been
dependent on the decisions that you make
so thank you for holding that
responsibility with care so i just
wanted to say that before i started
i've got to do too many things at once
here i've got to move my slides here so
here we go
march 2nd
was the two-year anniversary of the
first covid case in new hampshire and
march 13th will be the anniversary of
the governor's emergency order
those first few months
meant was a blur for many of us we had
insufficient ppe
the country ran out of the testing swabs
to stick up your nose
there was no vaccine everything ground
to a halt and we had no idea what would
happen next
two years later the unh survey center
suggests that seven in eight granite
staters likely have some protection
against covid19 either through
vaccination or through recent infection
since march 2020 there have been more
than three hundred 000 cases of coven 19
in new hampshire the highest rate
continues to be among 20 to 29 year olds
prime working age adults
january 15 2022 had the highest one-day
count
of
5724 new cases
reported on that one day
3571 individuals have been hospitalized
from a record one day total of about
478.
that and that was back in december to
the current number which is in the 70s
and for that we are all very grateful
about 40 kids have been hospitalized and
there have been 25 cases of something
called misc which is the worst
some of the worst outcomes that can
happen for kids it's a multi-system
inflammatory condition
and most devastating there have been
about 2 400 deaths of granite staters
since 2020.
we only have one death of someone age
zero to nine year old we only had one
confirmed pediatric death
we averaged a high of about 12 deaths a
day in december and early january
and just as vaccine became available and
we had about 750 cases per day then
one year later we have felt the
long-term effect of delta and the
beginning of omicron and we at the
beginning of omicron we were averaging
about 10 to 11 deaths a day
and that at that point we had 3 000
cases a day and i just mentioned that to
sort of look at the difference of where
we were and i'll scoot down to the next
slide you can see that
i'll get to in a minute we'll get to the
next part so
as a public health official i always
find it sobering to look at the leading
causes of death in our state throughout
my career here in public health this
list has guided our priorities and our
investments and while infectious
diseases are commonly found in the top
10 leading causes of death in low-income
countries never in our recent memory has
the u.s had an infectious disease in our
top ten never mind as the third or
fourth leading cause of death in the
state
covett has taught us that the gains
against infectious disease in the 20th
century through vaccine and therapeutics
cannot be taken for granted
due in much part to covid at the
national level life expectancy at birth
fell 1.8 years in 2020 from 78.8 years
in 2019 to 77 years in 2020 this was the
largest single year decline in more than
75 years since world war ii
early in the pandemic there were
individuals that questioned the validity
of this data of the death data the
underlying cause of death is the
condition that initiates the chain of
events that lead to a death
when the death certificate is filled out
by a physician the person who's
reporting the cause of death is asked to
identify that chain of events sort of
like a causal pathway
and working from that immediate cause
takes us to the underlying cause so an
example of that chain of event or a
pathway would be viral pneumonia due to
covet 19. that's the causal pathway
covid19 causes the viral pneumonia which
would then likely kill the person so
covid19 in that instance is considered
the underlying cause of death
regardless i think we can all agree that
more than 2 300 deaths in the state is
far can you take questions yes i will
representative i'm glad you touched on
that because that's a mystery to a lot
of people absolutely um
and
because most people it seemed like most
people who who died of covet had
co-morbidities
and what comes first the chicken or the
egg is it you know was it was a covert
that pushed them over the top to pass
away
or was there underlying cancer or heart
disease or whatever it might be and that
that but you were trying to explain
there's some kind of a tree here that
you yeah so absolutely so it would be
sort of like if you had cancer and you
died in a car accident so the cancer
didn't necessarily cause the car
accident that you died in but if you had
you know and i'm not a physician so but
if you had some sort of underlying
disorder because of that cancer or some
other condition that you know the car
accident led to that so the car accident
still is is there and the cancer is the
underlying you know component so you
know in the example that i just gave
which was around pneumonia people say
well you died in pneumonia you didn't
die of covet well the covid gave you the
pneumonia now in terms of like a chronic
disease which is what i think you're
talking about like a heart disease or a
diabetes again that person would have
not likely died that day you know with
just everything because
without the commit so you know we all
many of us in this country and in this
state and probably in this room all have
some form of chronic disease we're
likely not to pass away today from that
but with the addition of covid that is
what causes the death is that helpful uh
yes thank you representative mooney
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here and taking my question
i see on this list of ten causes of
death i don't see any drug related
illegal drug related um
overdoses right on there so i'm just
curious where that fits in sure knowing
the problems new hampshire has and
fentanyl making its way from the border
thank you um thank you very much for
that question representative mooney that
would actually be incorporated into
accidents which are unintentional
injuries so it sometimes falls within
that in fact in that case or you know
ultimately in intentional self-harm
so that's where you would find those
drug-related
you're welcome any other
representation
thank you mr chairman so the other thing
that
i don't know where it would be in this
list but i hear people joke about the
flu is gone nobody ever dies with the
flu anymore so is the flu
in one of these categories
um no it isn't so people still die of
the flu it tends not to be in our top
ten again of straight influenza now if
you have the chronic lower respiratory
diseases that's typically like copd
asthma again that's another example if
you have copd and you have the flu those
things go hand in hand together
okay thank you
okay
great thank you i'll slide on from here
so winter 2021
was deadly for our older population i
think we'll all remember the scare that
we had with long-term care facilities
you know the deaths were highest back
then in the 2020s which is where that
first arrow is was for individuals age
80 and older
vaccines did not become available until
late december 2020
excuse me and did not become available
for the public until january through
march of 2021
so you can see those dips right in there
we didn't that first arrow there were no
vaccines we started to get vaccines and
the number went down the delta came back
however with a hard punch
and those that were unvaccinated were at
higher risk for hospitalization and
death we saw our hospitals begin to
reach their breaking point as delta
swept through rural areas of the state
and then was replaced with omicron
omicron was even more transmissible and
is still transmissible it is still what
is circulating in the state but
fortunately it was a little less severe
than the delta variant
but the sheer number of cases that we've
had meant that even though the
proportion of people getting severely
ill was lower than delta or lower than
the strains before the number was higher
and we now see that deaths are more
likely to be those in their 60s rather
than those in their 80s
this is due in part to the very high
vaccine vaccination rates among those
age 70 and older lower vaccine uptake
among those in their 50s and 60s has put
them in higher risk
and what our data doesn't show quite as
clearly is again i think i mentioned
earlier that the unh survey center found
in january
they believe about 29 percent of
residents say they have tested positive
for covid at least once
let's move on to the next slide here
so that brings us to vaccination
vaccines have been at the center we have
another question representative
uh thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you
what is this chart showing i can't find
the key to it there's a blue line
there's the grays is it all cases
there's deaths in there too
thank you for that question that is the
blue line is the seven day average which
just sort of rounds out the numbers so
it's the seven day average of and the
the gray are the individual case counts
for that day so this is strictly cases
not deaths yes these are cases thank you
thank you
all right i'll move on to vaccines as
you've heard dr chan and others and the
governors say vaccines have been the
center of our covid19 response because
they are the best tool we have to
prevent hospitalization and deaths
covid19 vaccines are safe they're
effective and they're free and more than
two million doses of vaccine have been
administered in new hampshire in the
past year
um so i think i just sort of rest on
that a little bit one year two million
doses of
two and about two and a half million
doses of vaccine this is really an
incredible achievement it is brought to
the people by in new hampshire by
doctors by nurses by pharmacists by the
national guard our community and our
municipal volunteers our public health
networks and the incredible team that we
have at dhhs
no one should ever question the
dedication the hard work the sacrifice
and the competence of all of these
people vaccine has saved countless lives
here in new hampshire
and soon vaccines will even be available
for the youngest in the state it is
anticipated that the data will be
brought to the fda and the cdc later
this spring for approval for children
ages six months to four years old
many families who have navigated the
tricky waters of child care and
quarantine and loss of work and missed
work in school are going to welcome the
opportunity to consider vaccination
for their youngest children
so
the other thing i will note as we look
at these numbers i think it has been
well known
both in many of our legislative
committees and certainly within the
media we have had some difficulty in
counting some of our cases of that of
vaccine one of the things that we are
very you know pretty darn sure about is
this number of doses
because we count each dose of those
vaccines like they're gold we we track
them we make sure we know where they are
both at the state and the federal level
what becomes tricky is actually the
number of people who've received one two
three or four doses and how they are um
up to date or have had a booster and
that simply because is because of the
issues that we've had with our
immunization information system our iis
and the opting in and the opting out
process so while we can tell you the
number of doses who have been
administered there are some cases where
we can't link that to a particular
person within our current data system
because of those opt-outs so i just want
to be clear about that those two and a
half million doses that's a number that
we feel very confident about and
and i'm happy to take questions about
that later if you have any
let me ask a question right now is
uh
do you also keep track of the number of
doses that get wasted
yes we do we do keep track of that and
early in the vaccine delivery that was
super important because we had so little
vaccine and that's the reason you may
remember it feels like a blur and some
of us have ptsd and have blocked this
out
but we were dosing out so you'll
remember you know those 70 and older
started with vaccine and then we started
letting in groups we had 1a and 2 would
be and all these groups that came in and
that's because we didn't have enough
vaccine at the time now that production
is up and running we have more than
enough vaccine but we still keep track
of wastage
thank you
all right so vaccine distribution that
was one of the questions that you asked
us about again it's about two and a half
million doses
and you know i want to reiterate that
the vast majority of granite staters
have the protection of this vaccine
because of community partnerships we
have distributed vaccine at the new
hampshire motor speedway and inside
people's homes we've done it in retail
pharmacies through our regional public
health networks within communities our
health care providers you know the
national guard have the honor of putting
the most shots in arms
throughout this pandemic and again you
may recall those times and perhaps some
of you took part in those and early
vaccine days where you drove up and they
popped you a vaccine in your arm or you
know eventually you got to go into like
the old sears in concord and it was a
monumental task and we could not have
done it without the partnership of the
guard and the guardsmen and women who
were just extraordinary through this
process
so
as we go through we have also
put vans on the road and we brought
vaccine to workplaces and to people's
homes when they were too fragile to
leave
over 5 000 doses have been administered
on-site at workplaces from deca to the
shipyards in portsmouth
we have tried to make it as easy as
possible for people to get vaccine when
and what when they want it when and
where we've tried to accommodate work
schedules and people who work you know
different shift works um we have an
entire team that takes invitations from
workplaces communities churches who say
could you bring the van out to us for in
the early part for those early doses or
for a booster now and we still have
those vans going out throughout the
community now always at the invitation
of a community an organization or a
workplace
so what else have we done to support
businesses and you know as your
communities know best of all
you know our businesses have navigated
these complexities of the pandemic and
and have had the support of the cares
act and go for in the paycheck
protection plan and mostly have come out
on the other side
but early in the pandemic the governor's
reopening task force met daily to
provide feedback to public health and to
develop those universal best practices
we had over 2 000 clusters or outbreaks
in settings where people work play learn
and relax
there is not a business community that
hasn't been affected by sick workers
staff and and quarantine
the again that granite state poll
recently noted that most granite staters
now are comfortable going to hair salons
and restaurants and fewer than half are
really ready for big large group of
events like concerts or big weddings
but now with vaccine and therapeutics
easily available and people can feel
comfortable making their own decisions
to protect themselves and to protect
their businesses
from a public health perspective
and because we now have a high level of
infection or vaccine induced immunity
safe and affected testing and vaccines
and therapeutics it is fine to ease up
on those restrictions that we all felt
early in the pandemic you know we no
longer engage in universal case
investigation or contact tracing cdc
also agrees that that's no longer
recommended for covid19 we no longer get
daily reports from our schools this was
a huge relief to our school nurses
who were doing an incredible job again i
talk about the national guard of being
the heroes of this pandemic our school
nurses are really the heroes of this
pandemic as well they have undergone
incredible burdens so we no longer take
those daily reports
we do prioritize and help specific
settings or groups that are increased
risk if there's an outbreak in a nursing
home a school or a prison so we're
always there to help individuals
especially in those congregate settings
that are more at risk we're there we
still have a team but we're not doing
the routine
case investigation or that contact
tracing that you might remember from
earlier in the pandemic
so here's you know there's far more
optimism today than there was two years
ago we've come through some dark days
but our community risk is decreasing
omicron is in sharp decline
hospitals are no longer bursting at the
seams and soon even our youngest
residents will be able to have the added
protection that comes with vaccine
not on this slide
is the other strategy that will help us
through the trajectory of the pandemic
which is the widespread availability of
therapeutic drugs to treat covid19
paxlovid the name of a medication is
effective against developing severe
illness and it reduces hospitalization
it works by stopping the virus from
replicating and it remains in the body
without breaking down for a longer
period than some other previous
treatments
this is a major milestone for us the
president recently announced that there
will be a new federal test to treat
program
that will be starting within the next
week or so and this is working directly
with our retail pharmacies they will
have a cachet of effective antiviral
drugs making easy access in every corner
of the state and quite frankly the
country
when an individual gets tested at one of
those like cvs urgent care centers they
go in they get swabbed or they get
swabbed out in the parking lot if it
comes back positive if they're using an
antigen test you can be sort of moved
right over to the pharmacy component to
get access to the therapeutics that's
the notion is we want to be able to test
and treat as soon as possible for those
getting their care in their health care
providers or other places there will
also be and we currently have those
therapeutics available in those
environments and you would certainly be
able to get therapeutics by prescription
if you're you went to your family doctor
you could go and get a therapeutics very
quickly this is again a big game changer
because it really will continue to limit
the number of people that get so
severely ill that they need to end up in
the hospital we understand kovit is
going to be around for a good time you
know we still have cases we're in sharp
decline we're no longer at 5000 cases a
day we're down to you know under 200
cases a day but our goal at this point
is to make sure that there's testing
availability testing available it's a
reason you can get your your antigen
test at the liquor store right now we
want to make that easy so you know when
you're positive and then as soon as you
know when you're positive you have
access to therapeutics it's sort of like
tamiflu for the flu it can if you get it
early it really can help we have another
question representative rodney thank you
mr chair thank you thank you
additional question the second mystery
of covert for me
is
it seems like not all tests were created
equal
i i know so many people who say they
were tested in the morning positive but
then had a second test in the afternoon
and was negative
was that because of the type of test and
i think we've probably learned a lot
over the last year
about certain tests not being that
accurate is am i telling an untruth here
or is that true
um i think it's part of the truth um
that's my good bureaucratic answer right
there so you know again we stood up
those tests pretty quickly we've always
known that pcr tests are the gold
standard and that's what we started with
and that's where you send it out to a
lab the lab does its magic with it and
it comes up with a an answer antigen
tests those over-the-counter tests or
the antigen tests that even take place
in a doctor's office are less accurate
they're still pretty darn accurate but
they're certainly less accurate the
other component with those those at-home
tests and the antigen tests really it
you need to be shedding virus pretty
actively so in some cases i'll use an
example that you told me for early in
the morning you test positive in the
afternoon you test negative you know
that could also be because you might be
shedding less virus but you know i think
we've all heard about those cases where
that might be you know there may be some
question
but for the most part we know um through
again follow-up by pcr tests which
really are the gold standard that those
cases have been out there and you know
we had this high peak of omicron i don't
think it was the ta the tests that were
telling us that we certainly knew that
that was um in the in the community and
in fact speaking of tests it's one of
the reasons that we're no longer
accepting and um those at-home tests
that was actually part of what was
really hard for school nurses they were
trying to report back to us every time
johnny came in with an at-home test they
were required to report that to us we've
sort of taken that away and the the
count that we use today are the tests
that come to us through electronic lab
reporting which are the most likely the
pcr tests that occur in the lab is that
helpful yes uh one follow-up though um
so in the program you were just talking
about the therapeutics
you get swabbed it's positive you go
right in you get the therapeutics is
that going to be the pcr test um i think
it will be probably a mix of tests um i
think you know we will continue to
monitor i mean all of with all of these
drugs we'll continue to monitor we've
been sending out lots of support
to our healthcare physicians as the data
comes in on the effectiveness i think
many people noted in the media there was
an earlier um therapeutic drug that was
not good for omicron paxlovit is the one
that's good for omicron so we are we are
learning the science in real time um but
i think the the um
the risk benefit is greater of making
sure instead of saying oh i don't know
if that's really positive i'm not going
to take that therapeutic you know i
think the risk benefit is it's probably
better to take it and be sure that you
won't have a severe outcome and
especially as you were noting we have so
many people that with those precondit
pre-existing conditions that can put
them at higher risk if you had heart
disease and you tested positive on an
at-home test you should probably take
the therapy clinic thank you appreciate
that
all right
so representative element has a question
oh i'm sorry sorry
on
i'd
i've seen in various places including
from a
internet group in dc that a friend of
mine
got into a number about a year ago
that the
the tests
on
the at-home tests
that are sent to us in the mail
if they sit in our mailboxes for hours
when the temperature outside is 20
degrees
are not effective
thank you for that question we certainly
know that those tests were never meant
to sit out in harsh weather um you know
we're still finding it it's imperfect
and which is again why we say those pcr
tests are the gold standard you know if
you have symptoms of covid19 and they're
not resolving and you have an at-home
test and it says that you're you're
negative you should probably go to your
physician and have a pcr test done
thank you
ames
one of our guests earlier today
who was talking to us about
revenues
and in particular revenues from the
rooms and meals tax
suggested that uh we should anticipate
quoting larger than normal seasonal
swings due to rising cases he's talking
about covid
in the fall early winter so this
seasonal swing
uh idea what's your response to that
thank you for that question
we agree you know i think if you even if
i you know excuse me as i swing back
here
um if you look at those those bumps
those bumps occurred in the winter
and we will continue to probably see the
seasonality of covet you know our hope
again with testing with vaccine with
therapeutics is we can mitigate the
impact of severe disease we anticipate
that we'll continue to see some as the
variants change i didn't talk too much
about this but you know we actively
monitor here in new hampshire as well as
you know nationally
what the variants are over time and each
of the variants as we all learned with
delta and omicron
are slightly different some are more
transmissible
less severe some are more severe less
transmissional
thank you
great so as you can see
our pandemic response has changed over
time you know we started in the
beginning everything shut down we had no
supplies um people were at real risk we
saw that in that first winter when you
know um
covid ran through our long-term care
facilities and we lost so many of our
community members um at that time and so
the strategies that we put in place
change over time so now we have we start
with sort of that everyone closed down
we we created some mitigation measures
those were those universal best
practices that we gave to businesses and
other infectious infection control
practices and then you sort of move
through this continuum to when you have
vaccine and therapeutics and so that's
where we are right now
um it's we're not over but it certainly
is going to help us get to a place that
feels a little more normal for all of us
so in all of this time
we have had this hard balance of
competing priorities um you know we have
the covid19 control and mitigation
versus
our mental health our emotional health
our economy those things have been the
balance over the past two years and what
i think we're starting to see right now
is a tip from this graphic where those
issues around the economy and children's
mental health are tipping in the
direction because we have the vaccines
the therapeutics and the easy
access to testing that we didn't have
two years
ago
and so we're not the only ones seeing
this the cdc has also acknowledged this
and so they
realize we're in a new stage and so
like we are in new hampshire right now
which is really monitoring severe
illness and hospitalization
the cdc has put together a new way to
monitor community risk and that is by
really looking aiming at those
hospitalization numbers as well as the
coveted case numbers so this was just
announced last week there's a map on the
cdc website that goes county by county
and takes this math into consideration
and labels each county as
red yellow or green or high medium and
low i'm very happy to say that as of
this morning every state every
county in new hampshire is either low or
medium
according to this new framework
hillsboro rockingham and belknap are the
ones that are at low the rest are all at
medium risk and this is great news
that leads us to the other news that i
think many people applauded recently is
our current face mass recommendation
which simply states that with the
decreasing incidence and the continued
decrease in related hospitalizations
public health is no longer recommending
universal masking and you know i i sort
of took a moment myself even when i
walked in this building this is the
first time i've been in this building in
two years without a mask on
um and
we want to make sure that individuals
know that universe we're no longer
recommending that universal masking but
that individually you may have
considerations that make you want to
choose to wear a mask and we want to
ensure that people feel welcome and that
they do that because they may have their
own personal risk they may have an
additional
health condition there may be someone at
home who's on chemotherapy there are all
sorts of reasons why people may choose
to continue to wear a risk that are very
val wear a mask
that are very valid and but we want to
ensure that people know that that's
where we are right now is that we're
assessing our own personal risk and
making the decisions that are best for
us
there are a couple caveats though
there's always an asterisk
of which is if um
the current cdc guidance currently still
says if you have covet 19 you stay home
and isolate for five days you can come
back out if you're feeling well but it
does ask and require that you wear a
mask for those next five days till you
get to 10 days so that's one place where
we're really strongly recommending
people follow that because we don't want
to put other people at risk
so here we are
we're gonna continue with our other
prevention and mitigation strategies uh
we want everybody to still wash your
hands you know i was hoping people wash
their hands before the pandemic i kind
of hope they still wash their hands now
we want to make sure you test when you
have symptoms and you follow those
isolation and quarantine guidelines so
as not to make others sick and to put
others at risk
on the horizon we've got some new ways
to think about covet 19 and community
spread and monitoring the data and one
of these that i think is really exciting
is the surveillance of wastewater
colleges a couple of towns in new
hampshire are already doing this
dhhs already has a contract with the
university of new hampshire who monitors
the wastewater at new hampshire hospital
and this is a cost-effective tool that
really complements individual testing of
individuals so you can get a you know
get into that wastewater get into that
sewage and pull that out and actually do
a pcr test and it can tell you if
there's covid19 and the degree of coven
19 in that wastewater so it really is
sort of like just a signal it's a canary
in the coal mine it's telling you that
even before maybe individuals have
tested that there's some covid19
circulating out in the community um many
of us are pretty excited about this
right now i'm excited to be talking
about sewage
we're working with des
and exploring how we might expand this
data especially as we see the numbers go
down but we get ready for those upswings
come next fall and next winter
so covet's not going away yet and we're
going to continue to have risk we still
have 150-ish people a day testing
positive
but we have reasonable and sustainable
approaches on how to manage it those
approaches are not free this is ways and
means and finance i know you're
concerned about the money it takes
resources and it takes our community
partners to make it all work it's really
been an extraordinary two years
businesses the public have all endured
so much sacrifice
but because we have tools like easy to
access home testing vaccine therapeutics
we can get back to our more normal
routines safely
our job public health will can be to
continue monitor that data ensure that
we have the supplies and the technical
resources to support the community as
that data goes up and down
so i want to thank you all all of our
policy makers that have made it possible
for us to use all of these tools in our
toolbox to accept and to use the federal
funds that have been made available to
us to build relationships with our
communities and businesses so that we
could wade together through the
unchartered waters of the past two years
i want to thank you all of you for your
questions and your engagement and your
trust in us
to protect the people of new hampshire
it's been a privilege um to do this for
over two years so that's that's all i
have for now i'm i'm happy to take any
questions
mr telly
we are certainly appreciative of
coming here and providing this
information to us it's
it's a great um
great to hear that you're even doing new
things like checking the waste water
that
who would have thought
not me
so we appreciate that representative
ernest
thank you mr chair
could you clarify the distinction
between the immunization information
system and the vaccination registry
yes sure so those those two terms are
used interchangeably when the um
legislate when early legislation the
rsas were written it was called a
vaccine registry
as many of us know that have talked a
lot about the immunization information
system or the vaccine registry work on
developing that and that registry
happened
almost two decades started almost two
decades ago and has really been in
process for the past 10 years so again
originally when that was authorized it
was called the registry it is now called
the immunization information system
because it is much more than just a
registry of people it also is our entire
back end of our service of how you know
the questions around wastage it is how
we track vaccine when it comes into our
building where it goes out into the
community to make sure that
we can
ensure quality and safety for everyone
so you know if there were a bad batch of
varicella vaccines i don't even want to
talk about covid but a bad batch of some
vaccine early childhood vaccine we would
be able to know oh we gave that to
concord hospital and we would be able to
track it so that's some of the the
differentiations between those two terms
follow-up follow follow-up
so to clarify you're saying it's the
same database
where you record the vaccine dosage
stuff
as will you record
the people's vaccination status it it
they are components of the same database
so different modules this i will be much
like i say i'm not a doctor i am also
not an i.t specialist but they are
components of the same things because
those are often interrelated
again
managing just the process of managing
you know in this case two million doses
all of those doses didn't all come
through um the state of new hampshire
but still a million plus doses has come
through that system just the management
side of it and then we have sort of the
registry component which is the part
that i think there's been lots of
conversation about which is where you
know patricia tilley had a vaccine dose
on january 29th thank you
representative
thank you
26 years ago when i joined the
legislature on i was appalled to learn
that
the only public health officers
in the state
except for i think one person in hhs
were appointed at town level
frequently it was a plumber or an
electrician or there might be a doctor
who lived in town that was kind of told
could you do this on the side
um
suddenly
i think it was three years ago before
the pandemic started on the upper valley
had a public health council which is
apparently part of a network of 15 or
something public health councils
around the state
and the woman running it was
doing public health work
very well
and can you tell me how
how is this being financed and is it a
one-time thing that's going to disappear
again or
until the next pandemic
thank you very much for your question so
um you've touched on a couple of things
we still have health officers in all of
our community and those are you know
again
it depends community community sometimes
they're a doctor sometimes they're a
fire person
and they really work with the
municipalities on a lot of the
regulatory issues or coding or nuisance
issues they are also providing expertise
you know and recommendations and
especially in the beginning part of the
pandemic they were working with
businesses around restaurants around how
to manage um the guidelines around covet
19. but i think what your you really
spoke about was our public health
networks which are separate from that so
the health officers are part of the
municipal government
our public health networks we have 13 of
them around the state are really
community based organizations we fund
them with mostly federal dollars
federal dollars that do go up and down
but
in large part our public health
emergency preparedness money is called
fep
they receive a lot of those dollars
as well as some other pieces of money
that we've had over time and they're the
ones who've really been the boots on the
ground right now doing a lot of those
community
vaccine clinics and really engaging
with their hospitals and others you know
one of the things we're thinking about
right now are the vaccines for the
youngest children for the six month olds
to the four-year-olds nobody anticipate
you're not going to go through a
drive-through with a six-month-old
you're not going to go into an old sears
with a six-month-old we know that those
vaccines have to be given by
pediatricians those parents have
questions they want they need to have
answered before they would consider that
so our public health networks instead of
being the ones to put the shots in the
arms are actually now going to be
deployed to those health care workers to
help do some of the administrative
burden like you know getting people into
a clinic and and helping so those are
the sorts of activities that they do
it's funded by federal dollars the
federal dollars go up and down and they
do what we can afford to allow them to
do
representative tunisian
thank you mr chairman
the um
i think you mentioned that there's been
one death
and each death is unfortunate but one
death of a child from age zero to nine
and i know a lot of a lot of people i
talk to a lot of constituents people are
very nervous about giving their young
children the vaccine
given this type of data of one death
is and then of course you hear how
sometimes you know a child won't react
well and it can be life-threatening to
get the shot i mean
how what what do you recommend is a good
thing to to tell anxious parents
given that data that that's a great
question um this is this is a balance
for each family you know i think i've
been in several committees not
necessarily this committee but um others
you know the the department at this time
has no intention of requiring covet 19
vaccine for schools because we know um
families have questions we also know
that um you know children typically
don't have the most severe outcomes of
covid19 there was a death of a child
we've had 24 cases of this really
significant outcome however we know that
covid19 spreads easily when your kids
have it you know that grandma grandpa
yourselves your parents are at higher
risk if there's more more disease in
your house or more infections in your
house we also don't know what the
long-term effect of covid19 will be on
children
that's still up in the air and so i
think parents with their physicians make
the decisions that are best for them
given all weighing all of those odds you
know many parents have just like the
freedom that comes with a vaccine it's a
little less of something to worry about
from just a very logistical standpoint
they want to go to florida on vacation
and they want to make sure they have an
extra layer of protection that they
don't have to stay back home because
somebody is ill
follow-up
you mentioned that people might want to
do it so that they wouldn't spread the
disease but
it seems like
um
whether you're vaccinated or not i mean
i'm i'm vaccinated i got covet my wife
is vaccinated she got covered i know all
sorts of people that are vaccinated and
got copied so
i'm not does that i mean
everything else you said you know makes
sense but in terms of not spreading it
as much if you're if you're vaccinated
is that really what data do we have for
that so the data really is around viral
spread so it depends how much um you
know it we know if you are unvaccinated
you have greater viral shed than if you
are vaccinated so it has been suggested
that a number of people who have who are
protected by vaccine who get sick um
got it from someone who was unvaccinated
because they were had a bro a more viral
shed than others we also know that
there's a reason we had to do the
booster because we needed another little
bump up so those are all the
all of it is somewhat imperfect as we're
learning and that's why people just need
to make a
a decision based on their own personal
risks and the risks of their family
thank you
you know i'll just finish you know if
you have a family member who's going
through chemotherapy or is very immune
compromised you're gonna you might make
a different
decision than somebody else
any further questions
well thank you very much thank you
and for the committee members that are
still left here
enjoy your weekend yes you do
and thanks for uh
everything that you do
so next week we got a county meeting
above the executive
you